Save, underneath the water, child of the slaughter, sung it to your soul. Sound, swimming in the silence, daughter of the violence, sung into the void. Hey guys, it's Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast. That music that was leading it in is a new album by Caliphone that I'm really liking a whole lot. We had interviewed Tim Rutile from Caliphone last year. That was the album he was working on at that time, I'm guessing. So if you like the music, check it out. And also hop back and listen to the interview of Tim Rutile from Caliphone.
拯救，在水底，屠杀之子，向你的灵魂歌唱。声音，在寂静中游动，暴力之女，向虚无歌唱。大家好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的乔尔。刚才那段开场音乐是Caliphone的新专辑，我非常喜欢。我们去年采访过Caliphone的蒂姆·鲁蒂尔（Tim Rutile）。我猜那应该就是他当时正在制作的专辑。所以如果你喜欢这段音乐，不妨去听听看。也欢迎回头去听听对蒂姆·鲁蒂尔的采访。
He's a nice guy and I think he makes very interesting, weird music. I like to pick something that is relevant to the discussion with the guest, and the discussion with the guest today, I think that song and the outro are probably as relevant as I was going to find in the world of music. So our interview today is with Molly Adler. Molly has a podcast called Back from the Borderline, and she has another podcast that is about kind of esoteric anthropology philosophy that's to help you go to sleep. And if you don't go to sleep, learn something interesting. That one's called Night Night Bitch. You can find both of those wherever you get your podcast and follow her on Instagram. She's into depth psychology. She's into Western esotericism, and she's a really interesting person who I think holds the tension of the mystical and the logical
他是个很好的人，我觉得他做的音乐非常有趣且独特。我喜欢挑选与嘉宾讨论内容相关的东西，而今天与嘉宾的讨论，我觉得那首歌和片尾曲大概是我能在音乐世界里找到的最贴切的了。所以我们今天的采访嘉宾是莫莉·阿德勒（Molly Adler）。莫莉有一个播客叫《回到边缘》（Back from the Borderline），她还有另一个播客，内容是关于深奥的人类学哲学，旨在帮助你入睡。如果你睡不着，也能学到些有趣的东西。那个播客叫《晚安，碧池》（Night Night Bitch）。你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到这两个节目，也可以在Instagram上关注她。她对深度心理学和西方神秘学很感兴趣，她是一个非常有趣的人，我认为她能保持神秘与逻辑之间的张力，
in a way that some people are not able to out there, or they get pulled too far into one realm. I do want to give you a trigger warning. There are some pretty frank discussions about physical trauma medical trauma sexual assault and her history with the unfortunate realities of wealth and power that run her world so if that's something that makes you uncomfortable or you got kids around it may not be the best podcast but i'll go ahead and roll that and i was really glad that she's coming on and hopefully something that you might like her show also. So we will run that now. So I'm here with the great, great granddaughter of Alfred Adler.
这是有些人做不到的，或者说他们容易被拉向某一个极端。我确实想给出一个触发警告。节目中会有一些关于身体创伤、医疗创伤、性侵犯以及她个人经历的坦诚讨论，涉及那些掌控她世界的财富与权力的不幸现实，所以如果这些内容让你感到不适，或者周围有孩子，这可能不是最适合的播客。但我还是会继续播放，我很高兴她能来，也希望你可能会喜欢她的节目。那么，我们现在就开始吧。我和阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒（Alfred Adler）的玄孙女在一起。
No, not really. Not really. I'm here with the great great granddaughter of Alfred Adler. No, not really. Not really. I'm sorry. Let's not make anybody start doing some frantic Googling. No. I always do like a joke cold open. That's really good. I wish.
不，不是真的。不是真的。我和阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒的玄孙女在一起。不，不是真的。不是真的。抱歉。我们还是别让大家开始疯狂谷歌搜索了。不。我总是喜欢来个冷开场笑话。那真的很好。我希望是真的。
Well, I had planned for yours to be like, you know, like, have we ever met before? Is this your card? And then have a tarot card that was like the universe or something but the set that i have are um i brought them down to do it but the set that i have are like the clamped um ones and there's like boobs on all of them so which is like you know oh my god i never knew that she did a deck yeah it's i think it's just in the style of it's not actually like um it's something my wife had but i didn't want to be like oh just your cod And then like that seemed. That's actually really good.
嗯，我本来计划你的开场白是，你知道，比如，我们以前见过吗？这是你的牌吗？然后拿出一张塔罗牌，比如“世界”之类的，但我有的那套牌，嗯，我带下来想做这个，但我有的那套是那种夹着的，上面都有胸部图案，所以就像，你知道，天哪，我从不知道她做过一副牌。是的，我想那只是风格问题，并不是真的，那是我妻子有的，但我不想表现得像“哦，这是你的牌”，然后那样看起来……那其实真的很好。
I like both of them. I love, I would love to be the great, great granddaughter of Alfred, Alfred Adler. I would. Yeah. Well, I don't know if you'd never done a 23 and we maybe, maybe somewhere back there. Who knows? I'll have to email his family. Can I get a sample, please?
我两个都喜欢。我爱，我真希望我是阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒的玄孙女。我真的希望。是啊。嗯，我不知道你有没有做过23andMe基因检测，也许，也许在某个地方有联系。谁知道呢？我得给他的家人发邮件。能给我一个样本吗，拜托？
I'm seeing a lot of like small towns in Alabama with those cause these like huge ripples in because you only they only know it. They show you, you know, in a small town, it's pretty identifiable, right? Yeah. Like, I've had people told me about, you know, like, they know someone else knows this family secret, because that other person, it's like, oh, we know their results. So you know that they have your result too i know it's true like if somebody close to you does it you are you can already kind of like you know that you're screwed because it's already out there yeah there's like you know like some like the pastor you know in the 50s got around and some people are secretly siblings and then they're married like there's like all these crazy things that i've heard yeah that's a reality show waiting to happen.
我看到很多阿拉巴马州的小镇都有这些，因为它们引起了巨大的涟漪，因为只有他们自己知道。他们展示给你看，你知道，在一个小镇上，这很容易辨认，对吧？是的。就像，有人告诉我，你知道，他们知道别人也知道这个家庭秘密，因为那个人，就像，“哦，我们知道他们的结果。”所以你知道他们也有你的结果。我知道这是真的，就像如果和你亲近的人做了这个，你已经可以，你知道，你知道你完蛋了，因为结果已经泄露了。是的，就像，你知道，有些像50年代的牧师到处留情，有些人私下里是同父异母的兄弟姐妹，然后他们结婚了，就像我听说过所有这些疯狂的事情。是的，那简直是真人秀的素材。
Well, no one wants to talk about it, you know, especially not. They're still going to the same church. Yeah. So Molly has a podcast that I love. I don't know how you do the amount of research that you do to create the amount of content. And I really love to, I mean, there's a ton of people who are very bright and i mean well not a ton there there are a lot of people that are very smart and are very introspective and have done a ton of research that have really good shows um and there's a lot of people that have gone to therapy and gotten better but like you're incredibly candid about your life in a way that like you're not ashamed of anything and you shouldn't be. And like the realities of trauma. And I,
嗯，没人想谈论它，你知道，尤其是。他们还在去同一所教堂。是的。所以莫莉有一个我非常喜欢的播客。我不知道你是怎么做那么大量的研究来创造那么多的内容的。我真的很喜欢，我是说，有很多人非常聪明，我是说，不是很多人，是有很多人非常聪明，非常内省，做了大量的研究，有非常好的节目。嗯，还有很多人去接受了心理治疗并好转了，但你对自己的生活非常坦诚，以至于你对任何事情都不感到羞耻，而且你也不应该感到羞耻。还有创伤的现实。而且，我，
like I, that speaks so much to me because everybody who comes in with these things, like the therapy feels alone with them. And a lot of times the therapist has a business. So there, even if they've gone through recovery, they may say a little bit, but they're afraid,
就像我，这对我触动很大，因为每个带着这些问题来的人，就像治疗过程让他们感到孤独。很多时候治疗师有自己的生意。所以即使他们经历过康复，他们可能会说一点，但他们很害怕，
you know, until they're far into their career of saying like a lot of different things. And you just are so honest and your show and perspective evolves. And I don't know, so needed. I love it. I don't, I don't know how you're able to,
你知道，直到他们的职业生涯很长了才敢说出很多不同的事情。而你非常诚实，你的节目和观点在不断演变。我不知道，太需要了。我喜欢它。我不知道，我不知道你是怎么能够，
you must just like read constantly. Yeah. My husband laughs at me because I mean, I'm not diagnosed because obviously, you know how I feel about diagnosis. But my husband calls me the artist, like we call it the artist, but also the artist.
你一定只是在不停地阅读。是的。我丈夫嘲笑我，因为我是说，我没有被诊断，因为显然，你知道我对诊断的看法。但我丈夫称我为“艺术家”，就像我们称它为“艺术家”，但也指艺术家。
And I mean, I probably would get an autism diagnosis if I like sought it out. I'm for sure on the spectrum. And if you knew my family, like so many members of my family are also on the spectrum for sure if they went. But I take it as a superpower because I do, I read constantly to the point where I sometimes have to take a break because anybody who is kind of like a, you're probably the same, where you're constantly reading things and sometimes I have to go, whoa, sometimes I need to take a total detox. I'm actually in the middle of that now where I'm doing kind of a intellectual detox where I'm just kind
我是说，如果我寻求诊断，我可能会得到自闭症的诊断。我肯定在谱系上。如果你认识我的家人，我的很多家人肯定也在谱系上，如果他们去检查的话。但我把它当作一种超能力，因为我确实，我不断地阅读，以至于有时我不得不休息一下，因为任何像你这样的人，你可能也一样，你不断地阅读各种东西，有时我不得不说，“哇，有时我需要彻底排毒。”我实际上正处于那个阶段，我正在进行一种智力排毒，我只是有点，
of, okay, I think I need to integrate some of the things that I've been reading and you can get overloaded and then you also hit a point in your reading where you go it's all kind of the same thing said in different ways yes yes and you but you need to get to that point you need to read enough as a psychology student to realize your insecurity goes away because you're reading the same thing again. I see. And then you see the scope of history and the profession of the career, and you see the undercurrents of what these people are really fighting about. That's right. And the therapists don't get that.
好吧，我想我需要整合我一直在读的一些东西，你可能会超负荷，然后你在阅读中也会达到一个点，你会觉得“这都是以不同的方式说同样的事情”。是的，是的，你需要达到那个点。作为一名心理学学生，你需要读得足够多，才能意识到你的不安全感会消失，因为你在反复读同样的东西。我明白了。然后你看到了历史和职业发展的广度，你看到了这些人真正争论的潜流。没错。而治疗师们并不明白这一点。
I mean, it's like you'll see therapists go off on LinkedIn about how Jung is not evidence based or something. And it's like, well, yeah, just because you can't turn it empirical doesn't mean it's not evidence based. And just because you turn it empirical doesn't mean that it is evidence-based you know i've got a lot of research studies based upon crap that's just funded they share like this parts-based thing that they're training in and you're like schwartz put gestalt therapy together with you like ifs is a way to train an institution how to do yungi and gestalt therapy like that's
我是说，你会看到治疗师在LinkedIn上大谈荣格（Jung）不是基于证据的，或者类似的话。就像，好吧，是的，仅仅因为你不能把它变成实证的，并不意味着它不是基于证据的。仅仅因为你把它变成实证的，并不意味着它就是基于证据的。你知道，我有很多基于垃圾的研究，只是因为有资助。他们分享那种基于部分的训练，你会觉得“施瓦茨（Schwartz）把格式塔疗法和你的东西放在一起了”，就像IFS是一种训练机构如何进行荣格和格式塔疗法的方法，那就是，
what he did yeah and but there's no that no awareness of that. Like. No, there's not. And what's really interesting is I just did an interview with someone named Christian Bradley West. He calls himself the country clairvoyant on Instagram and he has an amazing background, but again, he's not a practitioner. He's just a lifelong student of these things. He started studying science science and nutrition and then he moved on to his own spiritual journey but he was just talking about how you know when he was studying into shamanism and all of these things so much of jung's work is in there and some people have an issue with jung because he supposedly stole his ideas but i just don't agree with that i think that when you start having with that i mean i thought
他所做的。是的，但对此毫无察觉。就像。不，没有。而且非常有趣的是，我刚刚采访了一个叫克里斯蒂安·布拉德利·韦斯特（Christian Bradley West）的人。他在Instagram上自称“乡村千里眼”，他有惊人的背景，但同样，他不是从业者。他只是这些东西的终身学生。他开始学习科学和营养学，然后转向了他自己的精神之旅，但他只是在谈论，你知道，当他研究萨满教和所有这些东西时，荣格的很多作品都在里面，有些人对荣格有意见，因为他据称偷了别人的想法，但我只是不同意这一点，我认为当你开始有那个时，我是说，我想，
you was tapping into a perennial philosophy too that's that's it what i mean is like is even if you were a little blob person out in the desert and you didn't have anything to draw upon if you started having mystical experiences you might start saying some of the same things that a lot of these mystics have been saying does that mean that that you've stolen your ideas? No. Why do we think of everything as stolen? And why can't we think of, whoa, look at all these connecting threads. They must be there for a reason. And you can't measure this by Cartesian thought. You can't nail it down and prove it. We have a really hard time not knowing well and that's one of the things that um i like complain about to the therapists that i'm friends with is that
荣格也在挖掘一种永恒的哲学。就是这样。我的意思是，即使你是一个在沙漠里的小斑点人，没有任何东西可以借鉴，如果你开始有神秘的体验，你可能会开始说出很多这些神秘主义者一直在说的话。这是否意味着你偷了你的想法？不。为什么我们认为一切都是偷来的？为什么我们不能想，“哇，看看所有这些连接的线索。”它们一定是有原因的。你不能用笛卡尔式的思维来衡量这一点。你不能把它钉死并证明它。我们很难接受“不知道”。嗯，这就是我向我认识的治疗师朋友抱怨的事情之一，就是，
like when you when academia is as hostile as it is to these new models because i don't like if you want to say okay well i only do risk evidence-based practice whatever okay why aren't you trained in, like, EFT or these things that outrank CBT? It's just, like, they use it as an excuse to not read research, you know. But, like, research is just used as a cuddle to keep new things out. It's not ever used to promote new models. And so, like, I don't really have a ton. And that's not, I'm not critiquing research as a concept. I'm critiquing academia as it exists right now and the kind of insecurity
当学术界对这些新模式如此敌视时，因为我不喜欢，如果你想说，“好吧，我只做基于风险证据的实践，什么的。”好吧，为什么你不接受EFT或那些排名高于CBT的东西的培训？这只是，就像，他们把它当作不阅读研究的借口，你知道。但是，研究只是被当作一种棍棒来把新事物拒之门外。它从来没有被用来推广新模式。所以，我真的没有太多。而且那不是，我不是在批评研究作为一个概念。我是在批评学术界目前的存在方式，以及那种不安全感，
that's in academia right now. But like when, when people, so I, it makes it very hard to tell if these new groundbreaking, especially in brain-based medicine, where the stuff is essentially like, it's not intuitive,
学术界现在存在的不安全感。但是当，当人们，所以我，这使得很难判断这些新的突破性进展，特别是在基于大脑的医学中，这些东西本质上是，它不是直观的，
you know, something like brain spotting, I thought was crazy until I did it. Something like ETT, I thought was crazy until I did it. I'm at the training and I'm still like, there's so many cranky chroma therapies in the 70s like they wore red glasses and said it would make your trauma go away or whatever like and and this guy has got this machine and it does this thing and it works and and i believe i you know
你知道，像大脑定位（Brainspotting）这样的东西，在我做之前我觉得很疯狂。像ETT这样的东西，在我做之前我觉得很疯狂。我在培训中，我仍然觉得，70年代有那么多古怪的色光疗法，比如他们戴着红色眼镜说它会让你的创伤消失什么的，而且，而且这家伙有这台机器，它做了这个东西，它起作用了，而且我相信，我，你知道，
i believe the people who told me it works so i was there but um you know this stuff's not intuitive so like until you do it you don't know yeah and you kind of have to be open for something to get through right so it's almost like if somebody who's totally closed off tries it and nothing happens they're like see it doesn't work and it's like uh is that true or is it the fact it's like people that are open to hypnosis are more easily hypnotized and if you're completely shut down um i don't know if that's a great comparison but you do have to have a certain amount of openness to your personality and i think people that are drawn to academia i'm not sure how much like openness and curiosity that they have sometimes because they they want things to be proven there's this rigidity that almost makes
我相信那些告诉我它有效的人，所以我去了。但是，嗯，你知道，这些东西不是直观的，所以直到你做了，你才知道。是的，你必须保持开放，让某些东西进来，对吧？所以几乎就像如果一个完全封闭的人尝试它，什么也没发生，他们会说“看，它没用”，就像，呃，那是真的吗？还是因为像容易被催眠的人更容易被催眠，如果你完全关闭，嗯，我不知道那是不是一个很好的比较，但你确实必须对你的个性有一定的开放性，我认为被学术界吸引的人，我不确定他们有多少开放性和好奇心，有时因为他们想要证明事情，有一种僵化，几乎使得，
it hard. And then also that you'll get a kick out of this. It's kind of a bit of a rabbit hole, but I think this is the perfect place to bring it up. I've actually never even talked about it on my podcast, but I had a listener who is just, she's been listening to me since day one. She's amazing. And she's going to school at a large school in california that will remain nameless and um she is now like going down she just got into a master's program for art therapy she asked me to write her a letter of recommendation for like her math program and i was going like and but as somebody who i don't have those credentials like it's but i did i wrote her a really heartfelt recommendation letter.
它变得困难。还有，你会喜欢这个的。这有点像个兔子洞，但我认为这是提出来的完美地方。我实际上从来没有在我的播客上谈论过它，但我有一个听众，她从第一天起就一直在听我的节目。她太棒了。她正在加州的一所大型学校上学，学校名字就不提了，嗯，她现在正在攻读艺术治疗的硕士学位。她让我为她的数学项目写一封推荐信，我当时想，而且，作为一个没有那些证书的人，这很难，但我确实写了一封非常真诚的推荐信。
And my podcast has made a big impact on her life, according to her. And her school, she was putting on this thing where they were bringing people in to talk about new perspectives on mental health. And in order to be accepted as a speaker, a plenary speaker, I had to interview with her supervisor. And this guy was so stuffy. And he sat down, I got on a Zoom call and my listener, Jenna, I know she wouldn't mind if I talk about her because she's just the best. And she told me, she's like, tell yourself, talk about yourself to this guy. And I just was very open about my experience and he kind of like was asking like what my credentials were and I was like a school of hard knocks like I don't know like lots of reading probably more than you've ever done bro
据她说，我的播客对她的生活产生了很大的影响。她的学校正在举办一个活动，他们邀请人们来谈论心理健康的新视角。为了被接受为演讲者，全体会议演讲者，我必须和她的主管面试。这家伙太古板了。他坐下来，我接通了Zoom电话，我的听众珍娜（Jenna），我知道如果我谈论她她不会介意的，因为她就是最好的。她告诉我，她说：“告诉你自己，向这家伙谈谈你自己。”我只是非常坦诚地谈论了我的经历，他有点像在问我的资历是什么，我就说“硬碰硬的学校”，我不知道，就像读了很多书，可能比你读过的都多，兄弟。
but I again I didn't say that I was very graceful because I just sensed his like skepticism right off the jump he like barely didn't even want he didn't even want to give me a chance. And, um, and he'd never listened to my podcast really. And so, and, and everything he brought up though, I, I just started talking about the biomedical model and my skepticism against it. And you could see him just like his butt clenching under his, like, he was just upset and triggered. Yeah. Really trying to keep it you know together and he was every question he was trying to like kind of like catch me out but everything he said to me i had a response for because i've read this stuff you know and i dropped out of my lmft program for a reason i was just like something in me knew that i didn't want to do this. But long story short, two weeks later, Jenna emails me and says, you know, he just thinks
但我再次强调，我没有那样说，我表现得非常优雅，因为我从一开始就感觉到了他的怀疑。他几乎不想，他甚至不想给我一个机会。而且，嗯，而且他从来没有真正听过我的播客。所以，而且，他提出的每一件事，我只是开始谈论生物医学模型以及我对它的怀疑。你可以看到他就像在他的椅子下紧绷着屁股，就像，他只是心烦意乱，被触发了。是的。真的试图保持，你知道，在一起，他提出的每一个问题他都试图像抓住我的把柄，但我对他说的每一件事都有回应，因为我读过这些东西，你知道，我退出我的LMFT项目是有原因的，我当时只是觉得，我内心深处知道我不想做这个。但长话短说，两周后，珍娜给我发邮件说，你知道，他只是认为，
that it's not appropriate for you to do this thing because you don't have any credentials. And I just was like, and she was so annoyed and she was so sorry. I'm like, don't worry about it. But ironically, now it's been, that was about a year and a half ago and the podcast has grown even so much since then. But I get written to by so many therapists, psychiatrists that are practicing in the NHS in the UK. And they are saying, thank you so much for your podcast. You say things that I actually can't even say.
你不适合做这件事，因为你没有任何资历。我当时只是觉得，她非常恼火，她非常抱歉。我说，别担心。但讽刺的是，现在已经，那是大约一年半前的事了，播客从那时起增长了很多。但我收到了很多在英国NHS执业的治疗师、精神科医生的来信。他们说，非常感谢你的播客。你说出了我实际上甚至无法说出来的话。
Yeah, the people with the license cannot say what you say. I say, hey, you should listen to Back From The Borderline. I think you'd really like this. And so me not getting my degree and not getting my credentials, I have a bachelor's degree, of course, but me not pursuing higher education has actually allowed me to have more success because I can say all of the things I want to say. And let me just say, I am not the type of girl that would have probably done well in higher education because I don't take orders very well. Yeah. Well, I mean, that was like, I was leaving the hospital when, I mean, one that I kept hearing like, well, you can reduce symptoms by talking to people, but we can give medicine. So stop doing
是的，有执照的人不能说你说的话。我说，嘿，你应该听听《回到边缘》。我想你会很喜欢这个的。所以我不去拿学位，不去拿证书，我当然有学士学位，但我不追求高等教育实际上让我取得了更大的成功，因为我可以畅所欲言。让我说，我可能不是那种在高等教育中表现出色的人，因为我不怎么听话。是的。嗯，我是说，那就像，我离开医院时，我是说，我一直听到的是，嗯，你可以通过和人交谈来减轻症状，但我们可以给药。所以停止做，
that. And I was like, well, but when you don't have erectile dysfunction, you don't go off your medication and you don't burn a building down. So me talking is you know because i was always like you know guys don't you think that because we were we were on a sort of community treatment team so we were treating the worst the worst cases of psychotic mental illness in the state and it was a lot of schizophrenia that was incredibly treatment resistant comorbid with something else like addiction and you know other things um but like the i don't know like that that whole thing like i was always like don't you think schizophrenia is like actually two diseases because there's like the people who have the more genetic presentation they are having like the positive symptoms and the people who have the more
那个。我当时想，嗯，但是当你没有勃起功能障碍时，你不会停药，也不会烧掉一栋楼。所以我说话是，你知道，因为我总是想，你知道，伙计们，你们不觉得吗？因为我们是在一个社区治疗团队，所以我们正在治疗该州最严重的精神病病例，那有很多精神分裂症，非常难以治疗，伴有其他疾病，比如成瘾，你知道，还有其他事情，嗯，但是，我不知道，就像那整件事，我总是想，你不觉得精神分裂症实际上是两种疾病吗？因为有那些基因表现更明显的人，他们有阳性症状，而那些有更多，
negative like symptoms those are the ones that like had a traumatic onset of the illness so you could have 20% of the genes and 80% of the trauma 80% of the trauma because these patients look like they have ptsd and they always have like an origin myth for why they have the illness like you know he raped me and put me in a closet and then it goes got to my body and so the ghost still talks to me or i was in the hospital and there's they switched my blood with the other blood and then now the blood you know what but it was like and they're like shut up the dsm says it's schizophrenia like i don't there's just no curiosity you know yeah people that want to use the degree as being like, Hey, look, this means that I'm smart. And it's like, no, I decide if on a case by case basis,
阴性症状的人，那些是经历过创伤性发病的人，所以你可能有20%的基因和80%的创伤，80%的创伤，因为这些病人看起来像是有PTSD，而且他们总是对为什么患病有一个起源神话，比如，你知道，“他强奸了我，把我关进壁橱，然后它进入了我的身体，所以鬼魂还在跟我说话”，或者“我在医院里，他们把我的血和别人的血换了，然后现在血，你知道什么”，但就像，他们说“闭嘴，DSM说这是精神分裂症”，我不知道，就是没有好奇心，你知道。是的，人们想用学位来表现得像，“嘿，看，这意味着我很聪明。”而这就像，不，我根据具体情况决定，
if I take you seriously and if your ideas are good. And also whether or not you're able to actually break through with some of these really difficult cases, you know what I mean? Your credentials don't actually mean anything and just like, well, they do, but they don't mean anything if you can't actually get down into the mud with people you know yeah yeah i mean and i just couldn't like i don't know i mean i when you said something that reminded me of this i hadn't thought about this in years but like right before i left and i went into private practice um i had a pride to work at the student counseling center and um they asked me like what is one of the most difficult cases you've ever done or something and i was like you know and i was like yeah you know this lady and has this lamp and her husband like cut the tendons out of her feet with scissors and
我是否认真对待你，你的想法是否好。还有你是否真的能够突破一些非常困难的病例，你知道我的意思吗？你的资历实际上并不意味着什么，就像，嗯，它们确实意味着什么，但如果你不能真正和人们一起陷入泥潭，它们就什么也不意味着，你知道。是的，是的，我是说，我只是不能，我不知道，我是说，当你说了什么让我想起这个时，我多年没想过这个了，但就在我离开并进入私人执业之前，嗯，我曾经在学生咨询中心工作，嗯，他们问我，比如“你做过的最困难的病例是什么”之类的，我当时想，你知道，我当时说，“是的，你知道这位女士，有这盏灯，她的丈夫用剪刀剪断了她脚上的肌腱，而且，
blah blah and like people were like like doing this like they wanted me to stop and it's like y'all asked me the question wait it was too much for them yeah Yeah. And then so like, anyway, they declined to hire me. And I didn't really like the program at all. Yeah. No, we mean the worst breakup anyone ever had with their boyfriend. It's college counseling. So I was like, so I called later just to be professional and was like, hey, you know, I didn't realize I didn't get the job and I want to be the best candidate I have.
等等等等”，人们就像，就像在做这个，他们想让我停下来，就像“你们问了我这个问题”。等等，这对他们来说太多了。是的。然后，所以，无论如何，他们拒绝雇佣我。我一点也不喜欢那个项目。是的。不，我们指的是任何人与男友经历过的最糟糕的分手。这是大学咨询。所以我当时想，所以我后来打电话只是为了专业，说，“嘿，你知道，我没意识到我没得到这份工作，我想成为我能成为的最佳候选人。”
So if you have any feedback for me, I'd love to do that. And the lady was like, you know, we think that you knew a lot more about therapy than a lot of people that we interview and hire. But we just think that somebody who's done like kind of a dirty job, like what you do, couldn't really do the advanced work that we do. And I was just like, biting my tongue, wanting to be like, just because you can't do what I do does not mean that I can't do what you do. What you do is easier than me. That's why I'm trying to get out. I say that for anybody who's early in their career and is looking for someone with more letters behind their name and feeling gaslit. Don't feel gaslit. It's not real.
所以如果你有任何反馈给我，我很乐意接受。那位女士说，你知道，我们认为你比我们面试和雇佣的很多人更了解治疗。但我们只是认为，做过像你做的那种脏活的人，可能无法做我们做的进阶工作。我当时只是，咬着舌头，想说，“仅仅因为你不能做我做的事，并不意味着我不能做你做的事。你做的事比我容易。这就是为什么我想离开。”我对任何职业生涯早期、正在寻找名字后面有更多头衔的人并感到被煤气灯效应（gaslit）的人说。不要感到被煤气灯效应。那不是真的。
Oh, I just have so much to say about that it's just it really brings up a lot because i just interviewed um bruce levine and he was talking about how sometimes like hairstylists can be better therapists oh my god therapist so much trauma and cosmetology man yeah because it's caregiving it's like it's a it's like the same personality type as like social work nurse teacher one of my best friends is a hairstylist and she just and she's also a very naturallyetic person. Like she's the kind of person that you could talk to her for two minutes and you're just telling her your life story no matter what. Cause she just, I mean, that's how I became friends with her is when I was in LA and very lonely. I make friends with my hairstylists wherever I go. And I think there's a reason for that because they're used to people kind of trauma dumping on them. and i was holding it shamanically
哦，我对此有太多话要说了，这真的引发了很多，因为我刚刚采访了布鲁斯·莱文（Bruce Levine），他谈到有时像发型师可以成为更好的治疗师。天哪，治疗师，美容业有很多创伤，伙计。是的，因为那是护理，就像，它就像社会工作者、护士、老师一样的性格类型。我最好的朋友之一是发型师，她只是，而且她也是一个非常自然有同理心的人。就像她是那种你可以和她聊两分钟，无论如何你都会告诉她你的人生故事的人。因为她只是，我是说，这就是我如何和她成为朋友的，当我在洛杉矶非常孤独的时候。我走到哪里都和我的发型师交朋友。我认为这是有原因的，因为他们习惯了人们对他们进行创伤倾倒。而且我当时在萨满式地，
holding it you gotta still cut the hair you know like she struggled she had to take breaks and i think a lot of hairstylists get burnt out and they don't realize why they're actually getting burnt out and it's yeah you're on your feet all the time and your back hurts and i mean doing hair is a hard job i i am a beauty school dropout my dad sings the grease song to me sometimes um i've done like a little bit of everything in my life but the thing that's the hardest at least from my friend's perspective is that is like people are unloading onto you all day long and you're kind of in just the listening mode because and that's a lot you know and so that's why i do have a lot of compassion for therapists right now too.
保持着它，你还得剪头发，你知道。就像她挣扎过，她不得不休息，我认为很多发型师会精疲力竭，他们没有意识到为什么他们实际上会精疲力竭，而且是的，你一直站在那里，你的背很痛，我是说，做头发是一份艰苦的工作。我，我是美容学校的辍学生，我爸爸有时会对我唱《油脂》里的歌，我一生中做过各种各样的事情，但从我朋友的角度来看，最困难的事情是，就像人们整天都在向你倾诉，而你只是处于倾听模式，因为，那很多，你知道。所以这就是为什么我现在对治疗师也有很多同情。
Cause like, let me tell you, I get anonymous emails from therapists a lot and they are not okay. They're not okay out here. But one of my really good friends just, it's kind of like teachers. They're like, people still think you're the man and you're like,
因为，让我告诉你，我经常收到治疗师的匿名邮件，他们并不好。他们在这里并不好。但我的一位好朋友刚刚，这有点像老师。他们就像，人们仍然认为你是“那个人”，而你就像，
I'm making compromises that let me see more people like i i wouldn't i would i could easily make more if i dumped insurance right now we're in a place where it's helping more people than it's hurting yeah we're kind of moving past that probably five six years from now insurance will be not that you know i hope that doesn't happen but you know there is a trajectory but like i'm i'm really making hard compromises to be effective to be the most effective that i can be and people will just be like well use the word patient and that's hierarchical medicine and you're canceled blah blah blah and it's like the number one search to my site is therapist accepting new patients you know there's an se if i can't fill up the people
我正在做出妥协，让我能看到更多的人，就像，我，如果我现在放弃保险，我很容易赚得更多。我们正处于一个它帮助的人多于伤害的人的地方。是的，我们有点走出了那个阶段，可能五六年之后保险就不会是那样了，你知道，我希望那不会发生，但你知道，有一个轨迹。但是，我，我真的在做出艰难的妥协以保持有效，以成为我能成为的最有效的，而人们只会说，“好吧，使用‘病人’这个词，那是等级森严的医学，你被取消了，等等等等”，这就像，我网站上的搜索第一名是“接受新病人的治疗师”，你知道，如果我不能填满那些，
who are working with me then like i don't know it's now you're at the mercy of seo and like all these things and that's one of the things that i have so much compassion for therapists because they're not the enemy you know this is a can i curse on this podcast oh please yeah part of the joke for me is that it's like the little corporate logo and it's like therapy podcast and you know it's going to be like the 10 tips for spring and then it's like meanwhile yeah no but like your guys are working in a really fucked up system right and you have to figure out it's like how rebellious can you be i would imagine like how can you be really rebellious and fight against the system while you still have yeah while you still have to work
和我一起工作的人，那么，我不知道，现在你受制于SEO和所有这些事情，这是我对比治疗师有这么多同情的原因之一，因为他们不是敌人，你知道，这是一个，我可以在这个播客上骂人吗？哦，请便。是的，对我来说，笑话的一部分是，它就像那个小小的企业标志，它就像“治疗播客”，你知道它会像“春天的10个小贴士”，然后它就像，与此同时。是的，不，但就像你们在在一个非常糟糕的系统中工作，你必须弄清楚，就像你可以有多叛逆，我想象，就像你如何能真正叛逆并与系统斗争，同时你仍然有，是的，同时你仍然必须在其中工作，
within it and that is just something I have so much compassion for because a therapist just emailed me the other day and she said, I was diagnosed with BPD when I was like, I think she was like 20 or something, 1920. And now she's a therapist and that part of her life is behind her. Of course, she doesn't have a fucking disordered personality because that's just nonsense. But she's like i hear such horrible things you know the the classic
而那只是我非常有同情心的事情，因为一位治疗师前几天给我发邮件，她说，我在我大约20岁左右，19、20岁时被诊断出患有BPD。现在她是一名治疗师，她生命中的那部分已经过去了。当然，她没有该死的紊乱人格，因为那只是胡说八道。但她说，我听到如此可怕的事情，你知道，经典的，
tropes being said about uh the borderlines you know and she's like having to like listen to that and not scream at these people like my peers when i know that i have that diagnosis but a i can't even defend because i can't say out, say out loud, I have that diagnosis and I'm just going, that's so wrong. You know, like it's you. I mean, I don't want to tell you about the history of that disorder because you have a whole podcast on it, but like, even based on the assumptions that they put into place that I don't agree with, they are still not using that diagnosis consistently with the assumptions that they put into place that I don't agree with, they are still not using that diagnosis consistently with the assumptions that they made to create it. I mean, if you are a woman and you
关于边缘型人格障碍的陈词滥调，你知道，她说她不得不听那些话，而不是对这些人尖叫，就像我的同行，当我明知我有那个诊断时。但A，我甚至不能辩护，因为我不能大声说出来，“我有那个诊断”，我只是在想，那太错了。你知道，就像它是你。我是说，我不想告诉你那个疾病的历史，因为你有一个关于它的完整播客，但就像，即使基于他们设置的我不认同的假设，他们仍然没有一致地使用那个诊断，基于他们设置的我不认同的假设，他们仍然没有一致地使用那个诊断，基于他们为了创造它而做出的假设。我是说，如果你是一个女人，你，
try to kill yourself and you go to the ER, you will get that diagnosis. They have no knowledge of what's going on. Is that a normal response to your environment? It's always what's wrong with you, not what happened to you. We get wildly different, you know, clientele at Taproot than I did when I was at a bigger firm, even though we're just a couple minutes down the street because we have totally different, we just attract a whole different kind of person. But like when I was at this other firm, I would get these referrals from psychiatrists that were like, this person's on a horse dose of sedatives. I can't sedate her anymore.
试图自杀，你去急诊室，你就会得到那个诊断。他们对正在发生的事情一无所知。那是对你环境的正常反应吗？总是“你有什么问题”，而不是“你发生了什么”。我们在Taproot得到的客户群与我在大公司时完全不同，尽管我们就在街下几分钟，因为我们有完全不同的，我们只是吸引了完全不同的人。但是，当我在那家公司时，我会收到精神科医生的转诊，他们说，“这个人正在服用大剂量的镇静剂。我不能再让她镇静了。”
And she has anxiety. Can you please do CBT now? And then I, which I don't love love cbt but the person would come in well what goes on at home my husband beats me okay well i'm not going to do zen meditation with you because we need to talk about why you want to get out of there really adjusted to her abusive environment you're well i mean i don't think the doctor knew and was enabling the husband but the fact that they didn't know and the medicine had been raised this amount of times i mean that's a problem and we probably that guy's overworked and at the mercy of another doctor and another board like i'm not saying that there's one
“而且她有焦虑症。你能现在做CBT吗？”然后我，我不喜欢CBT，但那个人会进来，“家里发生了什么？”“我丈夫打我。”“好吧，我不会和你做禅修，因为我们需要谈谈为什么你想离开那里。”她真的适应了她的虐待环境。你，好吧，我是说，我不认为医生知道并在纵容丈夫，但事实是他们不知道，而且药物已经被增加了这么多倍，我是说，那是一个问题，我们可能那个家伙工作过度，受制于另一个医生和另一个委员会，就像我不是说有一个，
villain when you start to make that kind of systemic diagnosis yeah it's the system and it's the incentives you know what i mean like they're incentivized on getting as many people in and out the door as possible they're incentivized on like numbing and suppressing quote-unquote symptoms they're what the incentives of everything is what's wrong it's the same reason why i wanted to get the hell out of working in tech like i just resigned from my tech job six months ago and god it was you know 10 years of working in different uh positions within uh software companies and i just was so infuriated by all the lying. You know, like it was just like every meeting, it's basically how can I make my numbers
恶棍。当你开始做出那种系统性诊断时，是的，这是系统，这是激励机制，你知道我的意思吗？他们被激励去尽可能多地让人进进出出。他们被激励去麻木和抑制所谓的“症状”。他们是什么，一切的激励机制都是错误的。这就是为什么我想从科技工作中解脱出来的同样原因，我六个月前刚从我的科技工作中辞职，天哪，你知道，在软件公司内部的不同职位上工作了10年，我被所有的谎言激怒了。你知道，就像每次会议，基本上都是“我怎样才能让我的数字，
look as good as possible? Even if we have a really low daily. Yeah. Oh, you just did two jobs at once. We're not going to give you a raise. We're going to realize that we don't need to hire somebody to do this other job now. Exactly.
看起来尽可能好？”即使我们有一个非常低的日活。是的。哦，你刚才同时做了两份工作。我们不会给你加薪。我们要意识到我们现在不需要雇人来做这份其他工作了。完全正确。
Even if the app sucks, even if everything everything it's just like everyone's hiding again the root cause right i'm going like i can't renew these customers not because i'm not good at my job it's because the app fucking sucks and the app doesn't have good use but then i have to lie to my my team and say okay let's see how we can make these numbers go up just a little bit so it's just like everyone's treading water and i feel like it's the same way in mental health it's the same way in academia and it's the exact same reason why our government fucking sucks too yeah well i mean you you it's like when people really need to believe that this guy or that guy is the solution to the other guy and you're like if you're excited about
即使应用程序很烂，即使一切，一切，就像每个人都在再次隐藏根本原因，对吧？我当时想，“我不能续订这些客户，不是因为我不擅长我的工作，是因为应用程序他妈的太烂了，而且应用程序没有好的用途。”但然后我不得不对我的团队撒谎，说“好吧，让我们看看我们如何能让这些数字稍微上升一点。”所以就像每个人都在踩水，我觉得在心理健康方面也是一样，在学术界也是一样，这正是我们的政府他妈的也很烂的完全相同的原因。是的，好吧，我是说，你，就像当人们真的需要相信这个家伙或那个家伙是另一个家伙的解决方案时，你就像，如果你对，
either of these choices you really just don't have the courage to look down okay like that's right you're running two different kinds of a dementia against each other and we don't have any good options yeah i'm gonna get a little political but it's like it's just like for me my dream candidate is like marianne williamson you know what i mean because i'm like at least here's someone who someone who's, and don't come for me people. That's one thing I don't have a ton of expertise in terms of like, I'm not going to be able to sit here and talk about her policy. But what I love about someone like her is that she's deeply spiritual and she's someone who actually thinks about things from a really high level perspective. And I just feel, and also she calls out these shitty incentives. know like and
这些选择中的任何一个感到兴奋，你真的只是没有勇气往下看，好吧，那是对的，你正在让两种不同类型的痴呆症相互对抗，我们没有任何好的选择。是的，我要变得有点政治化，但就像，对我来说，我梦想的候选人是像玛丽安·威廉姆森（Marianne Williamson）这样的人，你知道我的意思吗？因为我当时想，至少这里有一个人，一个，而且别来找我，伙计们。那是我没有太多专业知识的一件事，就比如，我不会坐在这里谈论她的政策。但我喜欢像她这样的人的一点是，她非常精神，她是一个真正从非常高的层面思考问题的人。我只是觉得，而且她也指出了这些糟糕的激励机制。你知道，就像，而且，
that's what and i'm not saying that she's the right person for presidency but i really love what she runs on you know like she did asmr like i would listen to her read the phone it's like oh same um but she when i listen to that i'm going like yeah we need a little bit more of that energy in our government whether she's the right person for the presidency or not. That's what I wish is like, I wish we had people that were actually thinking about virtues and thinking about the long term and thinking about getting wisdom from the past, but also going to the future. And it's just we have such faulty incentives. Well, the short term is the thing. You know, it's like, can you fudge this thing on this whatever for this app?
这就是，而且我不是说她是总统职位的合适人选，但我真的很喜欢她的竞选纲领。你知道，就像她做了ASMR，我会听她读电话簿，就像“哦，一样”。嗯，但当我听到那个时，我当时想，“是的，我们需要在我们的政府中多一点那种能量”，无论她是否是总统职位的合适人选。这就是我所希望的，就像，我希望我们有真正思考美德、思考长期、思考从过去获取智慧，但也走向未来的人。而且我们只是有如此错误的激励机制。好吧，短期是关键。你知道，就像，“你能在这个应用程序的这个什么东西上弄虚作假吗？”
Well, the app doesn't work. You know, it's like even after like andudge this thing on this whatever for this app? Well, the app doesn't work. You know, it's like even after like and everything. Having a mandate on shit. Yeah. I mean, it's in our system is designed that way. Like it's like, you know, you used to be able to take your phone to the AT&T store when it doesn't work. Now when your phone doesn't work, they're like, I really don't know how to work a phone here. All we do is sell them.
好吧，应用程序不起作用。你知道，就像即使在，弄虚作假这个东西在这个什么东西上？好吧，应用程序不起作用。你知道，就像即使在，和一切。对狗屎有授权。是的。我是说，它在我们的系统中就是这样设计的。就像，你知道，你过去可以在手机坏了的时候把它带到AT&T商店。现在当你的手机坏了，他们就像，“我真的不知道怎么在这里操作手机。我们所做的只是卖它们。”
You have to call this number. And it's like the company just took away your ability to get the help. It didn't fix the problem. Yes. And it's like the company just took away your ability to get the help. It didn't fix the problem. All of our short-term thinking, which I mean, really kind of starts in the 1980s. And a lot of what I write about is if you follow it to its root, going to be political, because what it's saying is that when you say that the point of health, when you corporatize academia and when you corporatize healthcare, you get a cognitive and a behavioral psychology. You're telling people that all they are, are their thoughts and their behavior.
你必须拨打这个号码。而且就像公司刚刚剥夺了你获得帮助的能力。它没有解决问题。是的。而且就像公司刚刚剥夺了你获得帮助的能力。它没有解决问题。我们所有的短期思维，我是说，真的有点始于1980年代。我写的大部分内容是，如果你追随它的根源，将会是政治性的，因为它的意思是，当你认为健康的重点，当你将学术界企业化，当你将医疗保健企业化时，你得到了一种认知和行为心理学。你是在告诉人们，他们所拥有的，只是他们的思想和行为。
And that's hollowing out of the profession to turn it into a number, because that's why CBT is popular. I mean, by the way, too, you know, I, I swear to God, I've been saying this way before AI and my phone is going off. I need to turn that off. Sorry. Like way before there was like AI or anything years ago, you know,
而那是职业的空心化，把它变成一个数字，因为这就是CBT流行的原因。我是说，顺便说一句，你知道，我，我发誓，我在AI之前很久就一直在说这个，我的手机响了。我需要关掉它。抱歉。就像在有AI或任何东西之前的几年前，你知道，
people were like giving, I was saying like, if you're saying that there is a manualizable form of therapy, that if the patient says this, oh, that's a cognitive distortion, snap the rubber band, tell the anxiety to stop,
人们就像是在给予，我当时说，如果你说存在一种可以手册化的治疗形式，如果病人说了这个，哦，那是认知扭曲，弹一下橡皮筋，告诉焦虑停止，
whatever. One, you're going to be replaced. You're you're, if you're saying that we should function like computers, you were paving the way for your job to be replaced by one. I mean, I turned down a job offer at a pretty big med tech company to program these computers for this module they were building to do CBT on people so that they could fire the therapist in the hospital. It was like, if you needed help getting your baby to breastfeed or something, you hit this button and then you don't have to have somebody come in.
什么的。第一，你会被取代。如果你说我们应该像计算机一样运作，你就是在为自己的工作被计算机取代铺平道路。我的意思是，我拒绝了一家相当大的医疗科技公司的工作邀请，去为他们正在构建的模块编写程序，以便在人们身上进行认知行为疗法（CBT），这样他们就可以解雇医院里的治疗师。就像是，如果你需要帮助让你的宝宝母乳喂养之类的，你按一下这个按钮，就不需要有人进来了。
It just- No shame, but if we're going to do these shitty cbt forms of therapy an ai might do it better than some of these burnt out i don't give a fuck therapists sorry shade but shade but it's true like yeah because people honestly somebody who is one of the therapists that i saw like again it's not her fault because again, she was probably burnt out, whatever, but came to this therapy session and just was like so low energy. So, um, just not there, like not present with me that I, I just felt like, what the hell am I even paying for? You know? And I am a huge fan of chat GPT. I use it all the time. It's incredible for me, but I also, I always, I talked a lot about this with Lawrence Hellman on our episode,
这只是——没有羞辱的意思，但如果我们非要做这些糟糕的CBT治疗形式，人工智能可能比其中一些精疲力竭、我根本不在乎的治疗师做得更好，抱歉，这是讽刺，但这是事实。因为说实话，我见过的一位治疗师，再次声明，这不是她的错，因为她可能精疲力竭了，无论如何，但来到这次治疗时，她的能量非常低。所以，嗯，根本不在状态，就像没有和我在一起，我只是觉得，我到底在付钱买什么？你知道吗？我是ChatGPT的忠实粉丝。我一直都在用它。它对我来说太不可思议了，但我总是，我和劳伦斯·赫尔曼在我们的那一集中谈了很多关于这个的话题，
because he's also a huge fan of AI. And we were just talking about how, you know, AI is only as good as the person who's using it. Like you really, I don't know how much you've messed around with it, but it's incredible. If I just used an AI to write my podcast episodes, they would suck. But what I use AI for is to help me organize my thoughts and it helps it feels like you know collates information really well the best metaphor i have for it is like if you imagine like a superhero movie where the superhero gets his arm chopped off and it's replaced with like a super arm like a super gold arm like that's how i feel chat gpt makes me it gives me like a super gold arm like i'm already great like i have to be a good superhero gpt makes me it gives me like a super gold arm like i'm already great like i have to be a good superhero but it makes me be able to like smash through things like
因为他也是人工智能的忠实粉丝。我们只是在谈论，你知道，人工智能的好坏取决于使用它的人。就像你真的，我不知道你尝试过多少次，但它太不可思议了。如果我只是用人工智能来写我的播客剧集，它们会很烂。但我使用人工智能是为了帮助我整理思路，它感觉就像，你知道，把信息整理得非常好。我能想到的最好的比喻是，如果你想象一部超级英雄电影，超级英雄的手臂被砍断了，然后被换成了一条超级手臂，就像一条超级金色的手臂，这就是我感觉ChatGPT带给我的，它给了我一条超级金色的手臂，就像我已经很棒了，我必须成为一个好的超级英雄，但它让我能够像粉碎一切一样
and that's how i use chat gpt and so i think it's amazing and i actually think that if these models are trained by people like you for example like i would much rather use an ai for therapy trained by you and get therapy from the woman i saw and i don't think people are talking about that enough they're just going oh no a computer can't give me therapy and i'm going no no we're thinking about this wrong well there's this push to turn there it will turn everything into gig work but therapy too i mean that's what i had that article about better help that went um it did numbers. But I really just write the articles to help SEO for our clinic, because you can pay for all this garbage content that's listicles, or you can write something that people actually reshare. And
这就是我使用ChatGPT的方式，所以我认为它很棒。而且我实际上认为，如果这些模型是由像你这样的人训练的，例如，我宁愿使用由你训练的人工智能进行治疗，也不愿从我见过的那个女人那里接受治疗。我不认为人们对此讨论得足够多，他们只是在说，哦不，计算机不能给我治疗，而我说，不不，我们对这个问题的思考方式错了。嗯，有一种推动力要把一切都变成零工，治疗也是如此。我的意思是，这就是我那篇关于BetterHelp的文章的内容，它，嗯，数据表现很好。但我写这些文章真的只是为了帮助我们诊所的SEO，因为你可以为所有这些垃圾内容付费，那些列表式文章，或者你可以写一些人们真正愿意转发的东西。而且
the but the I mean, BetterHelp did, you know, you know, and that's like, disregarding, like all of the people who said, like know my better health therapist walked through a conference room with me on video chat and people saw me or my better health therapist like walked into the office and got made popcorn you know during their session or something like but what they did i would lose my license i would lose my company like i wouldn't we wouldn't exist if an individual did that they took the data of those people and they sold it to Facebook. Disgusting. So that Facebook could take their medical problems and target ads at them saying,
但是，我的意思是，BetterHelp确实，你知道，你知道，而且这就像，无视了所有那些说，比如“我的BetterHelp治疗师在视频聊天中带着我走过会议室，人们看到了我”，或者“我的BetterHelp治疗师走进办公室，在他们的疗程中做了爆米花”之类的人。但他们所做的事情，我会失去执照，我会失去我的公司，如果我们中的任何一个人那样做，我们根本就不会存在。他们拿走了那些人的数据，并把它卖给了Facebook。真恶心。这样Facebook就可以获取他们的医疗问题，并针对他们投放广告，说，
oh, did your mom just die? This crystal helps with that. And they got fined less money than they made selling the data. Disgusting. You know, I turned down like a really big sponsorship opportunity from BetterHelp. Did you know that? No, I didn't. But I was was gonna ask you because that's oh i turned them down when you have this mental health awareness podcast and people say that and then you hear the ad from better help rolling and you're like not doing it i told my husband like i was like when i first started
哦，你妈妈刚去世吗？这种水晶对那个有帮助。而且他们被罚的钱比他们卖数据赚的钱还要少。真恶心。你知道，我拒绝了BetterHelp的一个非常大的赞助机会。你知道吗？不，我不知道。但我本来想问你，因为那是，哦，我拒绝了他们。当你有一个心理健康意识播客，人们这么说，然后你听到BetterHelp的广告在播放，你会觉得，我不做。我告诉我的丈夫，就像我刚开始的时候
because i just now have sponsors and my first sponsor was young platform so like yeah which is like the best sponsor for me. It's the perfect sponsor. Am I getting huge, massive payouts from them? No, but it's a long-term relationship that I can feel good about. Another one is a CBD company that one of my listeners works at. That is amazing. They've worked with the CrossFit Games.
因为我刚有了赞助商，我的第一个赞助商是Young Platform，所以，是的，这对我来说是最好的赞助商。这是完美的赞助商。我从他们那里得到了巨大的、海量的报酬吗？没有，但这是一段我可以感觉良好的长期关系。另一个是一家CBD公司，我的一位听众在那里工作。那太棒了。他们和CrossFit运动会合作过。
They're great. And so I can go to sleep at night knowing that I feel good about the sponsors that I work with. And I told my husband before I had any of these sponsors, I was like, guaranteed the first fucking offer I'm going to get is from stupid ass better help. I guarantee I already know it. And sure enough, and I took the opportunity to write, it was through a third party. And I wrote back this long ass thing, which is the only tweet of mine that's ever done numbers. And I wrote this long response back of why I was turning them down. And I went back, I went into detail about like their horrifying use of customer data. And the lady responded, she's like, thanks for the
他们很棒。所以我晚上可以安心睡觉，因为我知道我对合作的赞助商感觉良好。在我有任何这些赞助商之前，我告诉我的丈夫，我说，保证我收到的第一个该死的提议会来自愚蠢的BetterHelp。我保证，我早就知道了。果然，我借此机会写了，那是通过第三方进行的。我写回了这篇长篇大论，这是我唯一一条数据表现很好的推文。我写了这篇长篇回复，说明我为什么要拒绝他们。我回去，我详细说明了他们对客户数据的可怕使用。那位女士回复了，她说，谢谢你的
information I passed on to the brand. Not that they care, but I posted my response on Twitter and the amount of therapists that replied to me and said, thank you so much. Because every time I'm listening to a podcast and then that's supposed to be helping people with their mental health. And everyone in their dog is doing better health care. And wants to pretend like they get it and they're, you know, damn the man. And then they roll down for better help. I mean, one of this, this person, again, shall remain remain nameless is this girl that i follow i followed on instagram and she uh positions herself as like also a doctor which makes me laugh because like it's so misleading when you have like just like a doctor
信息，我转达给了品牌方。并不是说他们在乎，但我把我的回复发到了Twitter上，回复我的治疗师数量之多，他们说，非常感谢。因为每次我听播客，然后那本应该是帮助人们解决心理健康问题的。每个人和他们的狗都在做BetterHelp。并且想要假装他们懂，他们是，你知道，去他的体制。然后他们为BetterHelp做广告。我的意思是，其中一个，这个人，再次声明，名字保密，是我在Instagram上关注的一个女孩，她把自己定位为也是一名医生，这让我发笑，因为当你只有一名心理学博士时，这太误导人了
in psychology and you say i'm a doctor i'm just kind of like like she wears she wears like a white coat in some of her videos and i'm like bro, bro, are you okay? And she, I was watching just some random YouTube video last night. Are you dressed like a veterinarian? Exactly. That's exactly right. And against my will, I saw an ad pop up and it's sure as shit, it's her saying, are you feeling sad? Come to BetterHelp. And I'm like, oh my God. People just, do they even look, people just want to check. I mean, it doesn't even matter. At the end of the day, they're, and this same person, by the way, she fights against the stigma of labels.
当你自称医生时，我只是有点像，她会在她的一些视频里穿白大褂，我就想，兄弟，兄弟，你还好吗？而且她，我昨晚只是在看一些随机的YouTube视频。你穿得像个兽医吗？完全正确。就是那样。而且违背我的意愿，我看到一个广告弹出来，确实是她，她说，你感到难过吗？来BetterHelp吧。我就想，天哪。人们只是，他们甚至看吗，人们只是想检查一下。我的意思是，这甚至不重要。归根结底，他们是，而且顺便说一句，同一个人，她反对标签的污名化。
She does all this stuff. But in the same breath, you're going to advertise for a company like this. Well, here's what drives me nuts is, like, the boards, in theory, are a good thing. And then the way that they're used, it's only used to, like, hurt the poorest person or the person that has like no control over the system like they're never used to actually try and regulate whatever so like the lpc licensure is different social work has the strictest licensure out there which is what i am um because we work with the most vulnerable people and so like like for example and i mean this was the law being applied as it is written there was a lady who years back had this big practice and she was a therapist she was a social worker and so she had um it wasn't even like a
她做了所有这些事情。但在同一时间，你却要为这样的公司做广告。嗯，让我抓狂的是，理论上，委员会是一件好事。然后它们被使用的方式，它只被用来，比如，伤害最贫穷的人，或者对系统没有任何控制权的人。它们从来没有被用来真正尝试监管任何事情。所以，比如LPC执照是不同的，社会工作有最严格的执照，这就是我所拥有的，因为我们与最脆弱的人群一起工作。所以，比如，我的意思是，这是法律按其书面形式被应用，多年前有一位女士，她有很大的诊所，她是一名治疗师，她是一名社会工作者，所以她有，嗯，这甚至不是一个
support group it was just like a pre-internet like come to this coffee shop we're all recently divorced people that want to socialize oh and fly her up on the wall okay so guy goes there dates her breaks up with her guy's a lawyer calls the board you dated a patient board she's like i wasn't working i was in a coffee shop nope anything you do within the realm of mental health is social work practice for a social worker you can't turn your license off no and lpc whoa that guy is fucked up well yeah i mean obviously that there's you know talk about this person health half no have no fury like a woman scorned also health have no fury like a man denied just saying. Also, health hath no fury like a man denied.
支持小组，这只是一个前互联网时代的，来这家咖啡店，我们都是最近离婚的人，想要社交。哦，墙上的苍蝇，好吧，所以有个家伙去了那里，和她约会，和她分手了，家伙是个律师，给委员会打电话，你和一个病人约会了，委员会，她说，我没在工作，我在咖啡店。不，任何你在心理健康领域内所做的事情，对于社会工作者来说都是社会工作实践。你不能关闭你的执照。不，LPC，哇，那个家伙真是个混蛋。嗯，是的，我的意思是，显然，你知道，谈论这个人，“地狱无怒火，唯有被抛弃的女人”，还有“地狱无怒火，唯有被拒绝的男人”，只是说说而已。还有，地狱无怒火，唯有被拒绝的男人。
Just saying. Yeah, there's certain professions you got to be careful. Anyway. Damn. Well, yeah. So, I mean, that obviously he's being manipulative and I'm not defending any, you know, letter of the law, not the spirit of the law. But that's the letter of the social work law. What BetterHelp does, like, so i can't say i'm a
只是说说而已。是的，有些职业你必须小心。无论如何。该死。好吧，是的。所以，我的意思是，那显然他是在操纵，我不是在为任何，你知道，法律的条文辩护，而不是法律的精神。但这就是社会工作法律的条文。BetterHelp所做的，比如，所以我不能说我是
life coach on tuesdays and i do crystal healing and on on thursdays i'm a social worker and i do brain spotting i can't do that like an lpc can do that they can they can switch i cannot turn my license off i didn't know i cannot turn my license off in alabama that's the that's the one that i know so better help says you're getting therapy from a real therapist on all their ads these are real therapists they have licenses right you go through their paperwork and it says this person's not doing therapy okay so you can't hire social workers the board could say if you work for this company you violated your license you could economically undermine them you could do that in a second but we don't use the power that way oh because better help would sue
周二的生活教练，我做水晶疗法，周四我是社会工作者，我做大脑点位疗法，我不能那样做。像LPC可以那样做，他们可以，他们可以切换。我不能关闭我的执照。我不知道，我在阿拉巴马州不能关闭我的执照，这就是我知道的。所以BetterHelp说你在他们所有的广告上从真正的治疗师那里得到治疗，这些是真正的治疗师，他们有执照，对吧？你查看他们的文书工作，上面写着这个人不做治疗。好吧，所以你不能雇佣社会工作者。委员会可以说，如果你为这家公司工作，你就违反了你的执照，你可以从经济上削弱他们，你可以在一秒钟内做到这一点。但我们不那样使用权力。哦，因为BetterHelp会起诉
the board and then the board's in litigation with them but like yes that's your job as a regulatory agency what a mess also scary like that's another reason why i'm just so glad that i didn't go go through with that because i just don't think i could handle the anxiety of like am i saying the wrong thing am i doing do you feel like you're on like a leaf, you know, almost sometimes? Like, I guess maybe you get used to what you can and can't say. I am just the person who chronically over shares and like will always say too much or the wrong thing. And so I think it's probably like the universe was protecting me, like not finishing that.
委员会，然后委员会就和他们陷入了诉讼。但就像，是的，那是你作为监管机构的工作。真是一团糟。而且很可怕，就像那是另一个原因，我很高兴我没有完成那个过程，因为我只是觉得我无法处理那种焦虑，比如，我是不是说错了什么，我是不是在做，你感觉自己像是在一片叶子上，你知道，几乎有时？就像，我想也许你习惯了你能说什么和不能说什么。我只是一个习惯性过度分享的人，总是会说太多或说错话。所以我认为这可能就像宇宙在保护我，比如没有完成那个。
Maybe I'm stubborn and maybe I'm on the spectrum a little bit too or something. I probably could get that diagnosis if I went in. But it was like the hospital, like when I was leaving, I just couldn't do it. And you watch like the intuition get beaten out of these clinicians where it's like you're better off hiring students. But it was like we had a meeting every six months where they were like, hey, guys, we really want you to be honest and we want you to tell you what would improve the system a lot. Can you please do that? And please, you know, be honest and tell us. And we were overworked. It was like, I need these three hours. Like, I don't want to go to this
也许我很固执，也许我也有一点点谱系障碍或者什么的。如果我进去的话，我可能能得到那个诊断。但就像医院，就像我离开的时候，我只是做不到。而且你看着直觉从这些临床医生身上被击碎，就像你最好雇佣学生。但就像我们每六个月开一次会，他们会说，嘿，伙计们，我们真的希望你们诚实，我们希望你们告诉我们什么能大大改善系统。请你们这样做，好吗？请，你知道，诚实并告诉我们。而且我们工作过度了。就像，我需要这三个小时。我不想要去参加这个
meeting. And so I would always be like, okay, here's a list of stuff that if you did it, there would be no downside. The potential downside is like maybe a doctor who hasn't worked here in eight years feels a little bit insecure. But the upside is it's cheaper. There's less risk to the patient. There's less burnout. We are more effective. We're more profitable. This is the upside. Hey, hey, don't say that thing. And so after six of these meetings, I was like, I can't.
会议。所以我总是会说，好吧，这是一份清单，如果你做了这些，就不会有任何坏处。潜在的坏处是，也许一个已经八年没在这里工作的医生会感到有点不安全。但好处是它更便宜。对病人的风险更小。倦怠更少。我们更有效率。我们更有利可图。这就是好处。嘿，嘿，别说那件事。所以在那六次会议之后，我就想，我不能。
You're like, my feedback is to not have these meetings. And we're going to tell you that you want you to say something, but please don't say the thing that you always say. And I'm like, no, just don't have the meeting. You don't care. You know what I mean? I couldn't not do that. Literally, I couldn't do it it's kind of funny because it's the exact same thing in tech like we'd have our you know reviews and they're like please give me feedback as a manager and
你就像，我的反馈是不要开这些会议。我们要告诉你，我们希望你说点什么，但请不要说你总是说的那件事。而我就想，不，只是不要开会。你不在乎。你知道我的意思吗？我无法不那样做。真的，我做不到。这有点好笑，因为在科技行业也是完全一样的事情，我们会进行我们的，你知道，评估，他们就像，请作为经理给我反馈，而且
it's like you actually don't want to hear what i have to say trust me like it's much better if i say everything's going great because i already know it's not going to be impactful and the millions of like stand-up meetings that you have in tech like every morning every and it's just like the best thing you could do is cut out all of these meetings like nobody wants to go to meetings and nothing actually gets accomplished during these meetings I there were all these every meeting could be an email yeah all these articles were written during COVID where they were like we have all this data coming out right now that everybody is getting so much more done without mid-level management. Everyone's working from home and they're incredibly more effective.
就像你实际上不想听到我要说什么，相信我，如果我说一切都很顺利，那会好得多，因为我已经知道这不会有任何影响。而且你在科技行业每天早上都要进行的数百万次站立会议，就像，你能做的最好的事情就是取消所有这些会议，没有人想去开会，而且在这些会议中什么都没有真正完成。我，有所有这些，每次会议都可以是一封电子邮件，是的，所有这些文章都是在COVID期间写的，他们就像，我们现在有所有这些数据出来，每个人在没有中层管理的情况下完成的工作要多得多。每个人都在家工作，而且他们的效率要高得多。
What does this mean for the industry? And it means nothing because the ego of the mid-level manager is not going anywhere. And nothing was done with it. How many times did the Atlantic publish that during the COVID shutdown? Oh, yeah. I loved reading those because I'm like, nobody's freaking out except you. You know what I mean? Like that certain archetype of person, the rest of us that were like finally getting to work from home. reading those because i'm like nobody's freaking out except you you know what i mean like that
这对行业意味着什么？这意味着什么都没有，因为中层经理的自我不会去任何地方。而且什么也没做。大西洋月刊在COVID停工期间发表了多少次？哦，是的。我喜欢读那些，因为我就想，除了你，没有人惊慌失措。你知道我的意思吗？就像那种特定原型的人，我们其余的人就像终于可以回家工作了。读那些，因为我就想，除了你，没有人惊慌失措，你知道我的意思吗？就像那个
certain archetype of person the rest of us that were like finally getting to work from home and like do our work and then maybe do laundry and like run and get our groceries actually instead of having like three hours at night where we had our freedom we're loving it yeah well i mean that's what's so funny to me is these articles that they write about they usually tech companies but they they're like it's already it's like dude you won why are you complaining about how you won like you're you were on the system you wrote the rules you've changed the expectation of what an employer does we're not even having the conversation about whether or not you're going to get insurance and stuff anymore everyone's a gig worker you won and they're writing articles being like yeah these
特定原型的人，我们其余的人就像终于可以回家工作了，然后也许洗洗衣服，跑去买杂货，而不是像晚上有三个小时的自由时间，我们很喜欢它。是的，好吧，我的意思是，这就是我觉得非常有趣的地方，他们写的这些文章，他们通常是科技公司，但他们就像，这已经是，就像，伙计，你赢了，你为什么要抱怨你是怎么赢的？就像你，你在体制上，你制定了规则，你改变了雇主应该做什么的期望，我们甚至不再讨论你是否会获得保险之类的事情了，每个人都是零工，你赢了，而他们写文章说，是的，这些
people do four jobs um you know and and everything, nothing goes up based on inflation. But we just don't like how they talk about us on Facebook. We don't, we want them to like it more than they do. And it's like, well, why are you complaining that they're also not grateful? Like you got the money, just take it and be quiet, you know? And you never cared about anyone's feelings anyway. So why do you care now? You know what I mean?
人做四份工作，嗯，你知道，而且一切，没有什么基于通货膨胀而上涨。但我们只是不喜欢他们在Facebook上谈论我们的方式。我们不，我们希望他们比现在更喜欢它。就像，好吧，你为什么要抱怨他们也不感激呢？就像你拿到了钱，拿走它并保持安静，你知道吗？而且你反正也不在乎任何人的感受。那你现在为什么要在乎呢？你知道我的意思吗？
It's not feelings. It's the opinion of me. i mean it's not feelings it's the opinion of me yeah it's not right reality is not reflecting my erroneous self-image back to me so i'm gonna i'm gonna go on medium like write a sad letter in your journal about it that's what i always tell like myself when i'm when i'm ranting and raving like that just go write in your journal well um i you're and i i really uh i can't say this to a lot of guests but like you are really so big in all of the stuff that you've done with your history and your career that it's hard to even say well tell us a little bit about your story because all of those rabbit holes could just go on and on yeah i really was i decided to
这不是感受。这是对我的看法。我的意思是，这不是感受，这是对我的看法。是的，这不是，现实没有把我不正确的自我形象反映给我，所以我打算，我打算去Medium上写，在你的日记里写一封悲伤的信，这就是我总是告诉像我自己一样，当我在那样咆哮和发疯时，只是去写在你的日记里。好吧，嗯，我，你，而且我，我真的，嗯，我不能对很多嘉宾说这个，但就像，你在你所做的所有历史和职业生涯中真的太大了，以至于很难说，好吧，给我们讲讲你的故事，因为所有那些兔子洞都可以没完没了。是的，我真的，我决定
just kind of leave it open-ended, but I really had difficulty figuring out how to come up with any kind of structure. I mean, I don't want you to make you repeat what you have a whole bunch about. No, yeah, go ahead. Sorry. Yeah. It seems like the theme that we're on is like the, the insecurity and ego rigidity under a lot of the nefarious forces in our world yeah i mean for me i've i think that now knowing sitting where i am now i was spent a really long time in a very dark places mentally because i've gone down so many different like career rabbit holes like and your listeners can obviously
只是让它保持开放，但我真的很难弄清楚如何想出任何形式的结构。我的意思是，我不想让你重复你已经有很多内容的东西。不，是的，继续吧。抱歉。是的。看起来我们正在讨论的主题是，我们世界中许多邪恶力量下的不安全感和自我僵化。是的，我的意思是，对我来说，我想现在知道，坐在我现在的位置，我在精神上在非常黑暗的地方度过了很长一段时间，因为我走进了太多不同的，比如职业兔子洞，就像，你的听众显然可以
listen to my podcast but you know i have um done beauty school i went to college i've done sex work i worked in fashion i worked in tech i um you know i was um really really close to getting a record deal for singing and then it all fell apart because of um and at almost every single turn the theme of my life has been you know and i'm recognizing the the purpose of it now just from a spiritual perspective not to get too like woo woo but it's just like i the theme has always been um really predatory men honestly and i realized that they were everywhere you know like that's why i ended up like dabbling a little bit in sex work because i realized like if i'm just going to get objectified
听我的播客，但你知道，我，嗯，做过美容学校，我上过大学，我做过性工作，我在时尚界工作过，我在科技界工作过，我，嗯，你知道，我，嗯，真的，真的非常接近获得唱歌的唱片合约，然后一切都因为，嗯，而分崩离析。而且几乎在每一个转折点，我生活的主题一直是，你知道，而且我现在从精神的角度认识到它的目的，不是为了变得太像“呜呜”，但它只是，我，主题一直是，嗯，真正掠夺性的男人，说实话。而且我意识到他们无处不在，你知道，这就是为什么我最终，比如，在性工作中涉足了一点，因为我意识到，如果我只是要被物化
and sexually harassed like why don't i just make a job and actually yeah that's what y'all have money and because it's just like even when i was like a straight and narrow like i'm all i'm a good worker i kill it at whatever job i do whatever i've chosen to do i've been really good at it because i work really hard and that's how it's always been for me in school i've never been the person who like aces the test without trying that's my husband he's that person he'll like not study whatever, show up and just be good because he's naturally just ridiculously intelligent. Didn't go to college because he was like, fuck this. Very creative person and very smart. I worked really hard. I'm a people pleaser. I wanted to get the A and I barely would get the A. I would kill myself to get the A. And I've been always really addicted
和性骚扰，为什么我不直接把它变成一份工作，而且，是的，这就是你们有钱的原因。而且因为这就像，即使当我像是一个循规蹈矩的人，就像我，我是一个好员工，我在我选择做的任何工作中都做得很好，我一直很擅长它，因为我工作非常努力。这就是我一直以来的方式。在学校里，我从来不是那种不努力就能在考试中拿A的人。那是我的丈夫，他是那种人，他会，比如不学习，无论如何，出现并表现得很好，因为他天生就非常聪明。没上大学，因为他就像，去他的。非常有创造力的人，非常聪明。我工作非常努力。我是一个讨好型人格。我想要得到A，而且我勉强能得到A。我会为了得到A而自杀。而且我一直非常沉迷于
to people's opinion of me. So it's interesting that we're talking about that because I always cared what people thought of me. I was always just dying for validation and approval. And as soon as the internet was a really dark space because I grew up as a, I was born in 1989. So I was on the internet as like an 11, 12 year old girl on AOL Instant Messenger, like getting chatted to online by like probably old dudes knowing that I was young and there was no controls. Like if we think the internet's dangerous now, it was really dangerous for young people then because parents had no idea, you know what I mean?
人们对我的看法。所以我们谈论这个很有趣，因为我总是关心人们怎么看我。我总是渴望认可和赞同。而且一旦互联网是一个非常黑暗的空间，因为我是在1989年出生的。所以我作为一个11、12岁的女孩在AOL即时通讯上上网，就像在网上被可能的老男人聊天，知道我很年轻，而且没有任何控制。就像如果我们认为互联网现在很危险，那对当时的年轻人来说真的很危险，因为父母根本不知道，你知道我的意思吗？
What was going on? And so I got, I fell into patterns of being groomed and sexually abused by older men from a really young age. And then I think that I adapted to that and realized that I could manipulate kind of men to a certain extent. And, but at the same time I was getting abused and victimized. So that's a really hard dichotomy to hold, you know, like I, And for the longest time, I wouldn't allow myself to... I thought other women were victims of sexual abuse, not me, because I knew what I was doing, quote unquote. But in reality, I didn't. I was just a young girl. And I think I
发生了什么？所以我陷入了被年长男性从很小的时候就开始诱导和性虐待的模式。然后我认为我适应了这一点，并意识到我可以在一定程度上操纵男人。但是与此同时，我正在被虐待和受害。所以这是一个非常难以保持的二分法，你知道，就像我，而且很长一段时间，我不会允许自己……我以为其他女性是性虐待的受害者，而不是我，因为我知道我在做什么，引用引号。但实际上，我不知道。我只是一个年轻的女孩。而且我认为我
was just adapting to my situation and realizing that this was a way I could get attention and feel seen. And there's a lot of shame that comes with that. And then I moved into the working world and I realized it never stops. My bosses were sexually harassing me. My bosses were sending me suggestive Skypes and messages. And it's almost like there's that feeling that women know very well when it's like you think you're actually finally being seen for who you are and you get that first like over the line Skype from your boss and you're just going like really you know like okay I guess this is how it's going to be and now
只是在适应我的处境，并意识到这是一种我可以获得关注并感到被看见的方式。而且随之而来的是很多羞耻感。然后我进入了工作世界，我意识到它永远不会停止。我的老板在性骚扰我。我的老板在给我发暗示性的Skype和信息。而且几乎就像有一种女性非常了解的感觉，当你认为你终于因为你是谁而被看见时，你从你的老板那里得到了第一个越界的Skype，你只是在想，真的吗？你知道，就像，好吧，我想这就是它会变成的样子，现在
I have to play that part you know and and it's just hard it was really really difficult and it's just it happened wherever I went and then finally I got a manager in music that I really liked I was writing all my own music and then what happened a meeting at Soho house he tries to like ask me if I want to get a room with him he had a wife and kids and it was the one time in my life that I said no like I'm not doing this and the next day I got dropped by both him and my lawyer and so it's just like and it was right right after that, that I, you know, just, I had no, I had no mental, like my mental state was so bad. I didn't have the ability like mentally to get a job job again.
我必须扮演那个角色，你知道，而且这很难，这真的，真的很难，而且它发生在我去的任何地方。然后终于，我在音乐界有了一个我非常喜欢的经理，我正在写我所有的音乐，然后发生了什么？在Soho House的一次会议上，他试图，比如问我是否想和他开个房间，他有妻子和孩子。那是我一生中唯一一次我说不，就像我不会这样做。第二天，我和我的律师都被他解雇了。所以这就像，而且就在那之后，我，你知道，只是，我没有，我没有精神，就像我的精神状态太糟糕了。我没有能力，就像精神上再次找一份工作。
And so that's when I just started like working like these underground poker parties. One of my friends was a bottle service girl and I'll say bottle service is like the gateway drug into sex work. Really? Like, I'm not saying that every bottle service girl like the gateway drug into sex work really like i'm not saying that every bottle service girl ends up going into these things but there's a lot of areas of sex work that people just think that you become a prostitute that's not it you can work like a lot of different ways where you are getting money for being you know a companion for the darkest
所以那就是我开始，比如在这些地下扑克派对工作的时候。我的一个朋友是瓶装服务员，我会说瓶装服务员就像通往性工作的门户毒品。真的吗？就像，我不是说每个瓶装服务员都像通往性工作的门户毒品，真的，就像我不是说每个瓶装服务员最终都会进入这些事情，但性工作有很多领域，人们只是认为你成为了妓女，那不是，你可以以很多不同的方式工作，在那里你因为成为，你知道，男性心理最黑暗的
archetype of the male psyche and i also i wasn I wasn't great at that. I looked at other girls doing it because I, because I was very smart and because I could speak to men, like I, I could make it a really long time without getting intimate with people because they liked being out with me and they liked talking to me. But I realized also like, I'm probably someone who could get myself killed in this industry because I have a mouth on me, you know, like I'm probably someone who could get myself killed in this industry because I have a mouth on me. I'm not going to let someone talk to me any kind of way. And so a woman that I knew in one of those poker rooms, she looked at me and she's like, you need to get the fuck out of here. And she's like, you need to need to shut the fuck up or you need to stop doing this work because
原型而获得金钱。而且我也，我，我不擅长那个。我看着其他女孩这样做，因为我，因为我很聪明，因为我可以和男人说话，就像我，我可以坚持很长时间而不与人亲密，因为他们喜欢和我出去，他们喜欢和我说话。但我意识到，我也，我可能是一个在这个行业中可能会让自己丧命的人，因为我有一张嘴，你知道，就像我可能是一个在这个行业中可能会让自己丧命的人，因为我有一张嘴。我不会让任何人以任何方式对我说话。所以我在其中一个扑克室认识的一个女人，她看着我，她说，你需要滚出这里。她说，你需要，你需要闭上你的臭嘴，或者你需要停止做这份工作，因为
you're going to get yourself killed. And one of these rich guys can make you disappear. So you need to just think about that. And that made a huge impact on me. And I realized she was right. And so just that rabbit hole is to say that I know what it feels like to be in these really dark, dark places. I also know what it feels like to have to shove yourself into what I call on the podcast, the hot girl box to try to feel like you have worth. But now I'm recognizing that all that suffering actually served a purpose. And I'm finally doing the work that I know that I was meant to be doing, which is talking about this stuff. Nobody's talking about it. And there's still an epidemic of people, not just women. Because when I worked in fashion, I worked really closely with some of the male models. Many of these are very young men
你会让自己丧命的。这些有钱人中的一个可以让你消失。所以你需要考虑一下。这对我产生了巨大的影响。我意识到她是对的。所以那个兔子洞只是为了说，我知道身处这些非常黑暗、黑暗的地方是什么感觉。我也知道不得不把自己塞进我在播客中所说的“辣妹盒子”里，试图感觉自己有价值是什么感觉。但现在我认识到，所有的痛苦实际上都有一个目的。我终于在做我知道我注定要做的这项工作，那就是谈论这些事情。没有人谈论它。而且仍然存在着人们的流行病，不仅仅是女性。因为当我在时尚界工作时，我和一些男模特工作得很近。其中许多是非常年轻的男人
who are scouted from third world countries, who are sending all the money they make back to their families. They're living in squalor. And these really, really rich older gay men in fashion are basically giving them money for sexual favors. And I talked to some of these men and I was like, these boys and they laugh about it. They're like, oh yeah, and I'm not even going to get his graphic, but they're doing these things with these older gay guys. And I'm like, are you gay?
他们是从第三世界国家被挖掘出来的，他们把赚到的所有钱都寄回给他们的家人。他们生活在贫民窟里。而时尚界这些非常有钱的年长男同性恋者基本上是在给他们钱以换取性服务。我和其中一些男人谈过，我就说，这些男孩，他们对此一笑置之。他们就像，哦，是的，我甚至不会说他的图形，但他们正在和这些年长的男同性恋者做这些事情。我就说，你是同性恋吗？
Because I was one of the boys that I was kind of dating. I was like 23 and he was so hot. I mean, male models, that's a whole nother thing. But I was like, are you gay? And he goes, no, you just kind of have to block it out. Like I get money for it. So, and I'm like, and now I'm going the amount of dissociation, right? That you have to employ to do that.
因为我当时正在和其中一个男孩约会。我当时23岁，他太性感了。我的意思是，男模特，那是另一回事。但我说，你是同性恋吗？他说，不，你只是不得不把它屏蔽掉。就像我为此得到钱。所以，我说，现在我正在，那种解离的程度，对吧？你必须运用它来做到这一点。
And these boys that I met met they were so good at just like not not even thinking about it but we don't talk about that either it's even scarier as a young man i think to like admit to that because there's especially some of these boys they were from countries where homosexuality was seen as like this horrific thing, not a viewpoint I share, but this is happening, you know, and it's such a, it's such a, it's just so prevalent and it's so repressed. And so talking about this, just the wave of emails and voicemails and comments that I got, it's just like, I, I just struck a nerve and people are like, thank you because I thought something was wrong with me. I thought I asked for it. I thought that because I wasn't expressly saying
而且我遇到的这些男孩，他们非常擅长，就像，甚至不去想它，但我们也不谈论那个。作为一个年轻男人，我认为承认这一点甚至更可怕，因为特别是其中一些男孩，他们来自同性恋被视为像这种可怕的事情的国家，这不是我持有的观点，但这正在发生，你知道，而且它是如此，它是如此，它只是如此普遍，而且如此被压抑。所以谈论这个，我收到的电子邮件、语音邮件和评论的浪潮，它就像，我，我只是触动了神经，人们就像，谢谢你，因为我以为我有什么问题。我以为是我要求的。我以为是因为我没有明确地说
no and maybe I went out to a fancy dinner with this guy and then he was really nice to me and I actually kind of like him too as a person. It is so complicated. There's so much ambivalence and I don't know. I and so i know that i went through everything that i went through it now makes sense because back then i was just going why is this happening to me like is there like a mark on me that says like something well i think when you have that really heightened intuition people do sense it you know like you're not aware of what you're doing and that's why it's so important to make intuition conscious and not an unconscious function because yes it's you're making this connection with people that you're not wanting to make yes and i mean the people who
不，也许我和这个家伙去吃了一顿高级晚餐，然后他对我真的很好，而且我实际上也作为一个人有点喜欢他。这太复杂了。有太多的矛盾心理，我不知道。而且，所以我知道我经历了我所经历的一切，现在有意义了，因为那时我只是在想，为什么这发生在我身上？就像我身上有一个标记说，像什么东西？嗯，我认为当你拥有那种高度的直觉时，人们确实会感觉到它，你知道，就像你没有意识到你在做什么，这就是为什么把直觉变成有意识的，而不是一种无意识的功能是如此重要，因为是的，你正在与你不想建立联系的人建立这种联系。是的，而且我的意思是，那些
have your knowledge on the history of health care and psychology are not a lot of people and i wish that we did more of that in therapy but even the the ones who do, I haven't really found anybody, a couple of people, but really found many who are willing to be honest about the way wealth and power works and willing to understand it and look it in the eye. And you are, you know? Yeah. Well, and I kind of have had to, you know, because it's like, I, because of the spaces that I was in, just the mixture of things that I've done, like I said, it all makes sense now. The fact that I've worked in tech these like sexual sex work situations and how people are can like put themselves up on a pedestal but they're acting no different than just like the lowest of the low like I just think that men that find themselves in those spaces where they're
拥有你关于医疗保健和心理学历史知识的人并不多，我希望我们在治疗中能做更多这样的事情。但即使是那些做的人，我也没有真正找到任何人，几个人，但真的没有找到多少愿意诚实地对待财富和权力运作方式，并愿意理解它并直视它的人。而你是，你知道吗？是的。好吧，而且我不得不，你知道，因为就像，我，因为我所处的空间，只是我所做的事情的混合，就像我说的，现在一切都有意义了。我曾在科技界工作过，这些性工作的情况，以及人们如何能够把自己放在基座上，但他们的行为与最底层的人没有什么不同，就像我只是认为，在那些空间里发现自己的男人，他们
treating women like that and like if you're a man who is seeking out sex work and treating women the way that I was being treated because I do know that's something I really want to make clear there are sex workers out there that are a very special type of person who are like psychologically integrated and can actually do work that's healing and helping people but that is such a tiny fucking fraction and the fact that we are you know with only fans and saying this is empowering work it's not fucking empowering unless you are psychologically integrated and very few people are and so it's like that's why we have to fight against this stuff because you have to be to have
像那样对待女性，而且就像如果你是一个正在寻求性工作并像我被对待那样对待女性的男人，因为我确实知道那是我真的很想澄清的事情，有性工作者是那种非常特殊的人，他们心理整合，实际上可以做治愈和帮助人们的工作，但这只是该死的极小一部分。而且事实上我们是，你知道，有了OnlyFans并说这是赋权的工作，它不是该死的赋权，除非你是心理整合的，而很少有人是。所以就像，这就是为什么我们必须反对这些东西，因为你必须，为了
done a lot of inner work to be able to do sex work safely from a psychological perspective. And we're not talking about that enough. And it makes me feel so sad to know how lonely and broken so many women feel. And when I see the profiles of the girls that follow me on Instagram, and I see them, I see them pop up because if someone has a lot of followers, they pop up first on your likes. So they call like a priority like. So I've got almost like 100,000 people on Instagram now. And when another big account follows me or likes some of my thing, it pops up to the top.
从心理角度安全地进行性工作，已经做了很多内在工作。我们对此讨论得不够多。这让我感到非常难过，知道有多少女性感到孤独和破碎。当我看到在Instagram上关注我的女孩的个人资料时，我看到她们，我看到她们弹出来，因为如果某人有很多粉丝，她们会首先出现在你的点赞中。所以他们称之为优先点赞。所以我现在在Instagram上几乎有10万粉丝。当另一个大账号关注我或点赞我的一些东西时，它会弹到顶部。
And a lot of these girls, I know they're sex workers because they'll pop up to the top. They're gorgeous women. Their pictures are edited to where they look like fucking cyborgs. And I understand because I used to do that to my photos. So again, I am not judging anybody. And I had every injection under the sun. I had breast implants that I got removed. I dissolved all my fillers.
而且很多这些女孩，我知道她们是性工作者，因为她们会弹到顶部。她们是华丽的女性。她们的照片被编辑得看起来像该死的机器人。而且我理解，因为我过去常那样对待我的照片。所以再次声明，我没有评判任何人。而且我接受了阳光下的每一次注射。我做了隆胸手术，后来又取出了。我溶解了所有的填充物。
So again, I don't speak about shit that I don't know and I haven't done. So these accounts pop up and I click into their profile and I just look at their pictures and my heart just like breaks because I see them. They say, click the link in my bio. And I see their only fans link. And then they message me and they're saying, I want to kill myself. I love your podcast. Right. And I'm going like, and then look at the thing they're presenting, you know, this, this image they're presenting. And then the message they send to me, such a difference. And I know that when I had the Instagram with tens of thousands of followers, that's now deleted.
所以再次声明，我不谈论我不知道且没做过的事情。所以这些账号弹出来，我点击进入她们的个人资料，我只是看着她们的照片，我的心就碎了，因为我看到了她们。她们说，点击我个人简介中的链接。我看到了她们的OnlyFans链接。然后她们给我发信息，说，我想自杀。我喜欢你的播客。对。而我正在想，然后看看她们呈现的东西，你知道，她们呈现的这个形象。然后她们发给我的信息，差别太大了。而且我知道，当我拥有那个拥有数万粉丝的Instagram时，现在已经删除了。
That was for my music where I was so sexually presenting and all this stuff. I was suicidal and no one knew. And I don't know where I'm going with this, but it just breaks my heart and it's an epidemic and we're not talking about it enough. And it's the people that you don't want to judge people or scare them off or you mean you don't want to talk about your patient's experiences of course but that is so many people's experiences and the world is kind of gaslighting us yes that you're alone with it and you're not um it's just we've taken away every avenue to talk about it and it's easier if you want to you know not be honest with yourself about the pile of ill-gotten gains you're standing on to call it a personality disorder it's easier for a man to do that it's especially a man who's on the top of a company or the top of a hospital you know psychology was invented you know these founders like did it to
那是为了我的音乐，我在那里非常性感地呈现，所有这些东西。我当时有自杀倾向，没有人知道。我不知道我要去哪里，但这只是让我心碎，这是一种流行病，我们对此讨论得不够多。而且是那些你不想评判人们或吓跑他们的人，或者你的意思是，你不想谈论你病人的经历，当然，但那是很多人的经历，而且世界正在某种程度上对我们进行煤气灯效应，是的，你对此感到孤独，而你不是，嗯，这只是我们已经剥夺了谈论它的每一个途径，如果你想，你知道，不对自己诚实地面对你所站立的非法所得的堆积，称之为性格障碍会更容易。男人这样做会更容易，特别是处于公司顶端或医院顶端的男人，你知道，心理学是发明的，你知道，这些创始人这样做是为了
speak truth to power and then now it is you're not allowed to do that anymore you know i know and ironically some of the men that you see that are like saying oh she's borderline it's like these are the same manic pixie dream girls that you're fetishizing and cheating on your wife with. You know what I mean? So you're not examining your own shit. And these men are suffering too, right? So it's like that's what I've realized is like you really do. Like Marian Woodman is like one of my favorite depth psychologists.
对权力说真话，然后现在你不再被允许那样做了，你知道，我知道，而且讽刺的是，你看到的一些男人，他们就像说，哦，她是边缘型人格，就像这些是同样的“狂躁精灵梦女孩”，你正在恋物化并背着你的妻子和她们偷情。你知道我的意思吗？所以你没有审视你自己的烂事。而且这些男人也在受苦，对吧？所以就像这就是我所意识到的，就像你真的必须这样做。就像玛丽安·伍德曼是我最喜欢的深度心理学家之一。
And she does this whole lecture, which I've probably listened to more than than anything that i have and it's like holding the tension of the opposites and i just don't think that we have the capacity to hold the tension of the opposite right we over identify with one of the opposites yes and the opposite of truth is not lies it's certainty it's not that these things like integrate and then cancel out it's that you sit with the resonance of these two opposite parts of self that do not want to be in the same head until they reverberate and there's a harmony yeah and someone can be acting like a monster right and because when i was at the depth of my suffering i hurt a lot of people not physically you know i can still say that i've
她做了整场讲座，我听的次数可能比任何东西都多，讲座内容是关于如何保持对立面的张力，我只是觉得我们没有能力去保持这种对立的张力，我们过度认同了其中一个对立面，是的，真理的对立面不是谎言，而是确定性，并不是说这些事物整合后就会相互抵消，而是你要与自身这两个不想待在同一个脑袋里的对立部分所产生的共鸣共处，直到它们产生回响，形成一种和谐，是的，一个人可能会表现得像个怪物，因为当我在痛苦的深渊时，我伤害了很多人，不是身体上的，你知道，我仍然可以说我这辈子从未对任何人动过手，但我确实在心理上折磨过别人。
never put my hands on anybody in my life, but I have fucked with people's heads. Like I, I have sat and shed many tears over like the discord that I've brought into people's lives. You know, there were really good guys that I had in my life that like wanted to have something with me and I have broken them psychologically. Right.
就像我，我曾因为给人们的生活带来的不和而流下许多眼泪。你知道，我生命中曾有过非常好的男人，他们想和我建立某种关系，但我从心理上摧毁了他们。没错。
Like I have, because I was so fucked up in my own mind, like I didn't know what I wanted. I was so like, it was an emotional wrecking ball. Like I would be the girl that would go out with you and then get super drunk and then be like crying on the side of the road at 2 a.m. And, you know, making your friends be really embarrassed of like, you'd be like, dude, who the fuck is this girl you're dating right like i was that girl and i just i was the girl who was saying like you know wanting boyfriends like being jealous of their friends you know like like being super
就像我，因为我自己的思想太混乱了，我不知道自己想要什么。我就像一个情感破坏球。我会是那个和你出去约会，然后喝得烂醉，凌晨两点在路边哭泣的女孩。你知道，让你的朋友们感到非常尴尬，你会觉得，老兄，你到底在和什么样的女孩约会？没错，我就是那个女孩，我就是那个想要男朋友、嫉妒他们的朋友、表现得超级粘人的女孩。
needy and thankfully i found a partner finally who was so uh individuated and so like securely attached that he just wasn't putting up with that and not like in an abusive way he wouldn't play the games with me he was just saying i love you but i'm not doing that that's your shit it's not my shit and like he had this safe wall where i was like bouncing up against it and i was just like wait what like so none of my little games are gonna work on this guy like fuck and that's the eric green stuff yeah and because of that i had to look at myself and i had to say and he said to me he one of the most profound things my husband said to me my now husband we got married like six months ago but he was like you know
谢天谢地，我终于找到了一个伴侣，他非常独立，情感依恋也非常稳固，他根本不吃那一套，而且不是以一种虐待的方式，他不会和我玩心理游戏，他只是说我爱你，但我不会那样做，那是你的烂摊子，不是我的，他有一道安全的墙，我撞上去的时候，我就像是在想，等等，什么？所以我的那些小把戏在这个人身上都不管用？去他的，这就是埃里克·格林的那套东西，是的，正因为如此，我不得不审视自己，我不得不说，他对我说了我丈夫——我现在的丈夫，我们六个月前结婚了——对我说的最深刻的话之一，他说，你知道
i don't want you to be that bitter old person that's just complaining about the same stories forever and ever and ever. And I'm like, oh my God, you're right. I don't want to be that person. And he told me basically that he did not feel safe expressing himself emotionally in our relationship, not because I would hurt him or do anything, but it's because he's like, I just didn't want to deal with like the spirals that would occur. If I even just said like, Hey, I'm uncomfortable when you do X. And then I would be able to, because again, I'm very smart. I could like convince myself that I was making sense, you know? And that is what I think is scary too. And also what's not talked about when you're really smart and you're really
我不希望你成为那个永远抱怨同样故事的刻薄老人。我说，天哪，你是对的。我不想成为那样的人。他基本上告诉我，他在我们的关系中感到无法安全地表达自己的情感，不是因为我会伤害他或做什么，而是因为他说，我只是不想处理那些随之而来的螺旋式失控。即使我只是说，嘿，当你做某事时我不舒服。然后我就能，因为我还是很聪明，我可以让自己相信我是有道理的，你知道吗？我认为这也很可怕。而且当你真的很聪明、很有同理心但又没有实现个体化时，人们往往不会谈论这一点，你可以让自己相信几乎任何事情，并且你可以让它变得合情合理，尤其是对你所有的朋友。所以你告诉朋友们的故事就像是，天哪，是的，去他的那个家伙。没错。
empathetic and you're not individuated, you can convince yourself of almost anything and you can make it make sense, especially to all your friends. So the stories that you tell your friends are like, Oh my God. Yeah. Fuck that guy. Right.
然后你得到了所有这些肯定的回应，你会觉得，是的，我是对的，我是对的。在潜意识里，你通过搅浑水，让你的结论看起来像是科学的，是的，没错，所以服务于自我的智慧，我的意思是，有些人，你知道，他们最终发现寻求帮助要困难得多，因为他们太聪明了，以至于能够加倍努力，把这种神经症变成一件真正合乎逻辑的事情。而且你可以伪装起来，同时在工作中表现得非常出色，对吧？
And you're getting all these affirmative things and you're like, yeah, I'm right. I'm right. Unconsciously setting it up to make it look like what you're arriving at is actually scientific by you know muddying the water yes yeah and so intelligence in service of the ego is like i mean there's some people who you know they end up it's so much harder for them to get help because they're so smart that they're able to double down and make this neurosis like a real logical thing. And you can mask and be really high performing at your job at the same time, right?
并且在外面看起来非常成功。这就像我见过的第一个精神科医生。这是我播客里的著名故事。我说著名是因为我已经讲过很多次了，我走进那个精神科医生的办公室，我告诉你，我当时完全丧失了功能。我根本起不了床。我唯一能把自己从床上拖起来的时候，就是去赴当天的下一个约会，喝冰沙，因为我甚至无法
And be so successful on the outside. That's like the first psychiatrist I ever saw. And it's like the famous story on my podcast. And I say famous because I've just said it a lot where I went into this psychiatrist and I'm telling you, I was non-functional. I was not getting out of my bed. I was only dragging my ass out of my bed to go on like my next pinder date that i had of the day and like drinking smoothies because i couldn't
让自己去为自己做饭，但我还是把自己拖进了精神科医生的办公室，我显然看起来很体面，比如符合传统审美、什么的白人女孩，我告诉他我已经做了所有的研究，因为我神经质得要命，所以我说我知道我有边缘性人格障碍（BPD），这就是我有的，我读了所有的症状，我知道我有它，我当时有一种奇怪的、糟糕的观点，觉得如果我得到一个诊断，一切都会好起来，你知道我的意思吗？我认为这也是我们谈论不够的事情，就像我只需要得到一个自闭症诊断，我只需要得到一个自闭症诊断。我只需要得到一个多动症诊断。我只需要得到这个BPD诊断来确认我有这个。但对于那些人，我说，然后呢？所以我走进那个办公室说，这就是我有的。我知道。
even bring myself to you know cook for myself but i dragged myself into the psychiatrist office and i was obviously very presentable like conventionally attractive whatever white girl and he i told him i had done all my research because i'm neurotic as fuck and so i was like i know that i have bpd like this is what i have i read all the symptoms i know i have it and i had that weird fucked up view of like if i get a diagnosis everything will be better just you know what i mean which i think is also something that we don't talk about enough like i just need to get an autism diagnosis i just need to get an autism diagnosis. I just need to get an ADHD. I just need to get this BPD diagnosis to affirm that I have this. But then to those people, I say, then what? And so I went into that office and I said, here's what I have. I know it.
这就是正在发生的一切。我对他非常坦诚地讲述了我生活中的功能障碍，对吧？但他无法看透我的外表和我所做的研究，我告诉他我有多糟糕，我告诉他关于性工作的事，我告诉他所有这些事，但他却说，相信我，你不想得BPD，对吧？BPD是无法治愈的，我们要把你当作双相情感障碍二型来治疗，对吧？但他却说，你只是，他用的词是，你功能很高。我当时想，我根本不是。你对功能的定义是什么，兄弟？因为我根本无法正常生活。是的。
Here's everything that's going on. I was very open with him about the dysfunction of my life, right? But he couldn't see past my presentation and how much research i had done and i was telling him how fucked up i was i was telling him about the sex work i was telling him about all this stuff but he goes trust me you don't want bpd right bpd is incurable we're gonna treat you for bipolar too right and but he goes you're just the words he used was just like, you're very high functional. And I was going, I am not. What's your definition of functional, bro? Because I'm not functioning. Yeah.
但他无法看透那层外表，我认为丹尼尔·麦克勒是我最喜欢的YouTube创作者之一。他是一位非常激进的治疗师。我想他现在已经不干了。我不知道你有没有看过他的东西。他太棒了。哦，你会喜欢他的。你们，你们其实很适合上你的播客。
But he couldn't see past the veneer of, and I think that Daniel Mackler is one of my favorite YouTube creators. He's like a very radical therapist. I think he's quit now. I don't know if you've ever watched his stuff. He's amazing. Oh, you would love him. You guys, you'd actually be a great person to have on your podcast.
但他现在只是环游世界。就像我说的那样，他去非洲，背着包到处走，他只是谈论他为什么离开治疗行业以及所有这些事情。但他做了一个令人难以置信的视频，全是关于“美貌特权”的。他谈到了许多符合传统审美的美女是如何工作的。
But now he just travels the world. Like I say, he goes to Africa and like just kind of backpacks around and he just talks about why he left therapy and all these things. But he did this incredible video all about pretty privilege. And he talked about how like many kind of conventionally attractive women he worked.
他在像你这样的空间里工作。人们发现他自己在处理那些无法治疗的病例。他会被推荐。他们说，好吧，丹尼尔处理这些病例。他能搞定。所以他接手了所有对治疗有抵抗力的人。他说，你知道，很长一段时间以来，他与这些符合传统审美的女性一起工作，有一种东西叫“美貌特权”，基本上就是如果
He worked in spaces like you. People found himself treating the untreatable cases. He would get referred. They're like, okay, Daniel works with these cases. He gets through. So he got all of the treatment resistant people. And he said that, you know, for the longest time, time he's like he worked with these conventionally attractive women and there's this thing called pretty privilege where it's like basically if
你符合传统审美，你的生活就太容易了，你知道，这也是一件可怕的事情，因为你不能真正谈论它，因为如果你说，哦，我符合传统审美，我真可怜，生活真艰难，你知道，但他对这一点进行了非常精彩的剖析，他只是说，这些陷入其中的女性，吸引力在不同国家是不同的，你可以把我放在世界上的某个国家，他们会说，天哪，她真丑，因为我不符合那个国家的审美标准，但我白人，我有金发，我有蓝眼睛，我是一个还算有吸引力的人，所以在美利坚，因为我符合审美标准，我通常，你知道，可能被视为
you are conventionally attractive like your life is so easy and like you know and this is also a scary thing because you can't really talk about it because what you say oh i'm conventionally attractive woe is me life is hard you know but he does this beautiful unpacking of it where he just says like these women that fell into this and attractiveness varies in country you could put me in a country in the world and they'd say oh my god she's hideous because i don't meet the beauty standards of that country but i'm white i have blonde hair i have blue eyes and i'm like a decently attractive person so in america because i fit the beauty standard, I am usually, you know, maybe seen
那样。但发生的事情是，我的一生，自从我十几岁以来，我感觉我只是被视为，好吧，首先，现在我三十多岁了，我根本不在乎。我想，现在没有人会物化我，因为一旦有人试图这样做，他们就会想，哇，别在那个女人身上浪费力气了。但当我十几岁的时候，我真的很想要那种认可，我没有意识到那会让你变得多糟糕
as that. But what happens is, is that my whole life, like ever since I became a teenager, it's just like, I feel like I'm only seen as like, well, first and foremost, now that I'm in my thirties, I don't give a fuck. I'm like, nobody's like objectifying me now because as soon as someone even tries, they're like, they're like, whoa, don't even try with that one. But when I was a teenager and I really wanted the validation, like I didn't realize how bad that can fuck you up
因为你没有被视为你自己，你知道吗？你一直被告知，关于你，重要的东西并不是真正重要的东西。完全正确。而且还因为你拥有这些令人向往的特质，所以你似乎不可能在受苦，而实际上，是的，你可以。你可以正在受苦。而且有一半的时间，哦，你为什么要抱怨？你是一个顺性别异性恋白人女性。你一定拥有世界上所有的特权。而实际上，我出生在一个拖车里，我的一半
because you're not seen for yourself, you know? You're being told all the time that what is important to you about you is not what's important about you. Exactly. And also that you somehow can't be suffering because you somehow have these desirable traits when in reality it's like, yes, you can. You can be suffering. And also half the time, oh, why are you complaining? You're a cisgendered heterosexual white woman. You must have all the privileges in the world. When in reality, I was born in a trailer and half my
家人来自阿巴拉契亚。我离拥有很多特权还差得远，但我知道这其中有一个因素。所以再次强调，我认为有些人陷入了这种感觉，我甚至能谈论我的挣扎吗？因为我看起来没有足够的“受害者标签”来证明我的挣扎。这有意义吗？所以这非常孤立、孤独和令人困惑，你真的会对自己进行煤气灯效应，对吧？是的，我不知道我是否在你的节目中回溯得足够远，但我还没有完全赶上之前的节目。你说的很多内容让我想起，你有什么关于直觉和创伤之间关系的特别内容吗？
family is from Appalachia. And I am far from having a lot of like privilege, but I know there is an element of that. So again, I think some people are caught in this feeling of, can I even talk about my struggle because I'm not seen to have enough marks against me to validate my struggle. Does that make sense? So it's very isolating and lonely and confusing and you can really gaslight yourself too right yeah i i don't know that i've gone pretty far back on your show but i'm not totally caught up with the backlog a lot of what you were there's a lot of content reminds me of like do you have anything specifically about the relationship between intuition and trauma?
我谈论过很多关于那个话题。我的论点是，精神痛苦中最大的一部分是我们与直觉断开了连接。你知道，我们与我们的直觉感受断开了连接，然后它就变成了神经症，对吧？这就是问题所在。就像我与灵性修行者交谈得越多，有些人非常有直觉。有些人确实有千里眼。有些人确实有这些额外的感知能力。但如果你处于一个创伤世界中，我刚刚做了一个关于创伤世界的三部分系列，我称之为，你被困在偏执的咕噜（Gollum）能量中。
I've talked a lot about that. And what I, my, my thesis is, is that the hugest part of mental suffering is the fact that we're disconnected from our intuition. You know, we're disconnected from our gut feelings and also then it turns neurotic, right? Like that's the thing. It's like the more I speak to spiritual practitioners, some people are very intuitive. Some people literally are clairvoyant. Some people literally do have these extra kind of like sentient capabilities. But if you are in a trauma world, I just did this three-part series on trauma worlds where I call it like you're stuck in paranoid Gollum energy.
就像如果你拥有所有这些惊人的直觉能力，但如果上面有一层创伤面纱，就像我们之前谈到的，你可以让任何事情变得合情合理，你是妄想的，所有这些自然的直觉能力，是的，我的意思是，这就是我听你侧面谈论过的，我只是不知道是否有一集，我想我没有做过专门的一集，是的，那是我对你所说内容的解读，因为我总是把那个概念化为，对于病人来说，直觉是一种你真的无法关闭的功能，是的，很多人有能力去回避它，但创伤让你无法回避那种关系，是的，直觉，但它很多时候所做的是，创伤触发了这种深深的
It's like if you can have all these amazing intuitive capabilities but if it's there is a trauma veil over them it's like we talked about before you can make anything make sense you're delusional and all of these like natural intuitive faculties yeah i mean that's what i've heard you talk about it like tangentially i just didn't know if there was a an episode I don't think I've done like a specific episode yeah that was kind of my read of what you'd said because I always conceptualize that with patients that like intuition is this function that you really cannot turn off yes and a lot of people have the ability to avoid it but trauma makes you not be able to avoid that relationship yeah intuition and and but what it does a lot of times is trauma sets off this deeply
潜意识直觉，所以你看到了所有这些你并没有意识到你是如何看到的信息，而你使用直觉的方式，这不是一种选择，所以你正在与那些你并不真正想联系的人建立联系，你在解读你不想解读的情绪，你在帮助你不想帮助的人，你知道，很多时候，就像你，因为你刚才说，你知道，大约20分钟前关于，你所有的旅程是如何带你去某处的，这就是我所听到的，你知道，就像创伤开启了直觉，你只是很长一段时间不知道该怎么处理它，但你真的，当你拥有那种
unconscious intuition so you're seeing all this information that you that you're not aware of how you're seeing it and the way you're using intuition it's not a choice so you're making all these connections with people who you don't really want to connect with you're reading emotions that you don't want to read you're getting you're helping people you don't want to help you know and that so much of the time it's's like when you, because you were saying, you know, about 20 minutes ago about the, how all your journey was taking you somewhere, and that was kind of what I was hearing, is that, you know, like the trauma turned the intuition on, you just didn't know what to do with it for a long time, but you really, when you have that
直觉，你可以做任何事，你可以拿到唱片合约，你可以做这个，我的意思是，这是一种听到某种东西的能力，这就是为什么你知道很多人会问，这个模式是邪教还是不是，我总是觉得那个问题很有趣，因为学术界对这些新模式非常敌视，当我接受史蒂文·巴斯克斯（Steven Baskets）的ETT培训时，他一点也不觉得这很有趣，但我说，你知道，我希望学术界对这类东西不要那么敌视，因为你知道，当每个人都说，哦不，这是最好的东西，而且他太聪明了，你真的需要学习它，你不知道它是不是邪教，直到你去做了，你知道，像这样，他说，不不不，我们不认为它
intuition, you could do anything, you could get the record deal, you could do this, I mean, it's this ability to hear hear something and and that's why you know a lot of people are like is this model a cult or not and i always think that question's really funny because academia is so hostile to these new models um when i got trained with ett with steven baskets he didn't think this was funny at all but i said you know i wish academia wasn't so hostile to stuff like this because you know like it makes models of psychotherapy when everyone's like oh no this is the best thing and like he's so brilliant and you really need to learn it and you don't know if it's a cause or not until you go do it you know like and uh he goes no no no we don't think of it
像个邪教，我们更喜欢称它为家庭，我说，哦，所以你知道你们的台词，然后他确实说了，我敢打赌，是的，我肯定他说了，任何说他们是家庭的人，我在科技行业听得太多了。就像，这不是工作。我们是一个家庭。每当有人这么说的时候。当我们想让你工作的时候，而不是当我们分红的时候。是的。而且直到你毫无预兆地解雇我，我的谷歌账户在一个月内就停止工作了，这在科技行业发生过。那真的不太像家庭。好吧，也许也许是，这是一个功能失调的家庭系统，我有一个朋友在一家科技初创公司工作，他看到了健康科技初创世界或什么的恐怖之处，基本上公司，所有者意识到他们制造的这个东西，我得小心保持匿名，但是的，他们意识到这个东西制造的责任太大了，超过了公司可能赚取的任何利润，所以他们就都解雇了自己
like a cult we prefer to call it a family and i said oh so you know your lines and then he did i bet yeah i'm sure he didn't anything anyone says they're a family, I got that so much in tech. It's like, this isn't work. We're a family. Whenever anyone says that. When we want you to do work, not when we're splitting up the profit. Yeah. And also until you lay me off with no notice and my Google account just stops working in one month, which has happened to me in tech before. That's not really very family. Well, maybe maybe it is it's a dysfunctional family system i had a friend who worked for a tech startup and he just saw the horrors of the health tech startup world or whatever and there was like basically the company like the the owners realized that the this thing that they had made was i got to be careful to keep this anonymous but yeah they realized the thing that this made that the liability was too much it outweighed any profit the company was ever going to make so they just both they fired themselves
从公司，是的，但如果有人进来，说嘿伙计们，我们的公司不存在了，并且实际上解雇了员工，那将是参与，而他们当时不想参与，所以没有人知道，直到他们从乡村俱乐部的人那里听说他们的公司没了，所有这些需要这种医疗服务的客户都在打电话，没有人知道该说什么，也没有人能联系到他们的老板，我的意思是，这就像，我的意思是那个行业的那些事情简直太离谱了，当那家制造生物眼睛的公司出现时，报道被误报了，你知道我在说什么，大约一年前在新闻里，我不知道，我不认为我看到了那个，那是一个植入物，
from the company yeah but if anyone came in and said hey guys our company doesn't exist anymore and actually laid off staff that would be involvement and they didn't want involvement at that point so no one knew until they heard like from someone at the country club that their company was gone and all these customers were calling meeting this medical service and no one knew what to say and no one could get in touch with their boss i mean it's just like i mean the stuff in that sector is so beyond the pale like it got misreported when there was that camp company that was making biological eyes you know i'm talking about it's like in the news about a year ago i don't i don't know i don't think i saw that it was an implant that
用微小的电脉冲刺激你的视网膜，这样如果你失明了，你就能看到黑白图像，哦哇，他们在人们的眼睛里安装了这些摄像头，然后被误报了，新闻里说公司破产了，但这些东西上的固件需要更新，而公司只是停止了这样做，人们把它植入了自己的大脑，哦，而且对此没有任何监管，所以，但他们说，报道说公司已经破产了，那不是真的，公司决定里面没有足够的钱，就停产了，所以，他们还在那里，所有拥有这些东西的人都陷入了困境，是的，哇。哇。这让我想起，实际上，这很有趣，
stimulated your retina with little electrical impulses so you could see a black and white image if you were blind oh wow they put these cameras in people's eyes and then it got misreported they said in the news that the company went bankrupt but the firmware on these things had to be updated and the company just quit doing it and people had it implanted in their brain oh and there's no regulation about that so but they said in the the reporting said that the company had gone bankrupt that wasn't true the company decided there wasn't enough money in it and discontinued the product and so like and they're still there all the people that have these things just in the shitter yeah wow. Wow. It reminds me of actually, it's interesting,
一个非常相似的情况。我25岁住在伦敦时做的隆胸手术，我发现，我不知道你有没有听说过隆胸疾病。
a very similar situation. The breast implants that I had that I got when I lived in London when I was 25 years old, I found out, and I was, I don't know if you've ever heard about breast implant illness.
这是一个真实存在的事情，人们可能会因为各种不同的原因而因隆胸手术生病。它会导致慢性免疫问题。我经历了因隆胸手术而导致的衰弱症状，我根本不知道这与它们有什么关联。我见过的每一位医生，从来没有一次，当然他们会问你做过什么手术？我总是说隆胸。从来没有一次他们说，嘿，也许这可能与你体内这些巨大的硅胶块有关。
It's a real thing and people can get sick from their breast implants for a variety of different reasons. It can cause like chronic immune stuff. And I experienced debilitating symptoms from my breast implants that I had no idea what was correlated to them. Every doctor that I saw never once did they, of course they ask you what surgeries did you have? And I always said breast implants. Never once did they say, Hey, maybe this could be connected to these like huge chunks of silicone in your body.
嗯，奇怪，对吧？就像也许那可能是一个原因。我收到了一份通知。嗯，我想是在我隆胸三年后，来自FDA，长话短说，他们说这些纹理的“软糖熊”植入物，也就是我用的那种，被标记为会导致癌症，并且正在被召回，好吧，你能想象收到一封邮件说你体内的东西，而你是一个在洛杉矶身无分文的穷光蛋，负担不起任何东西，这感觉如何？公司不需要来，他们不需要做任何事，所以他们不需要说，嘿，我们要付钱让你把这些取出来，所以最终我去了蒂华纳，我没开玩笑，去把这些取出来。所以最终我去了蒂华纳。我没开玩笑，去把我的隆胸植入物取出来。谢天谢地。而且我没有贬低的意思。我得到了一些最好的医疗护理。我做了很多研究。我有一个最棒的医生，我对他哭诉，他非常
Um, weird, right? Like maybe that could have a reason. I got a notice. Um, I think it was like three years on into my breast implants and it was from the FDA and long story short, they said these textured gummy bear implants, which is what I had, they were flagged for being causing cancer and they were being recalled okay and can you imagine how it feels to get an email saying that like the things that are in your body and you're a broke ass bitch in la that cannot afford like anything i was already the company doesn't have to come they don't have to do anything like so they don't have to say hey like we're gonna pay for you to get these removed and so like i ended up going to tijuana i shit you not to get these removed. And so like, I ended up going to Tijuana. I shit you not to get my breast implants out. Thankfully. And this is no shade. I had some of the best medical care. Like I did a lot of research. I had the most amazing doctor who I cried to him and he was so incredibly
支持我，他尽快帮我安排了手术。他把它们取了出来，而且，我不会说出他的名字，因为实际上，我甚至不认为这是合法的，但我对隆胸手术太害怕了。重要的是他们要取出包膜，也就是植入物周围形成的疤痕组织。当我跟他谈话时，我太害怕了，我说，求求你，求求你，求求你取出包膜。求求你不要在这个手术上走捷径。因为我当时非常刻板印象。
supportive and he got me in as soon as possible. He got them out and he, and I won't name him because it's actually not, I don't even think it's legal to, but I was so scared with breast implants. It's important that they take, they remove the capsule, which is like the scar tissue that also forms around the implant. And I was so scared when I talked to him, I said, please, please, please remove the capsule. Like, please don't shortcut this surgery. Cause I was being very stereotypical.
我只是认为去蒂华纳，你会得到一个草率的手术。没错。但他说了，他听了我的话。我在哭。当我手术出来时，他在恢复室走过来对我说，第一，我想给你看点东西。他拿出手机，让他的护士记录了整个手术过程，这样我就可以看到。他举起包膜，在镜头前说，看，它们没了。没错。
I just thought going to Tijuana, you're going to get a slap job surgery. Right. But he said, he listened to me. I was crying. And when I got out of surgery, he came over into me in the recovery room and he said, number one, I wanted to show you something. And he pulls out his phone and he had his nurse record the whole surgery so that I could see. And he held up the capsules and like in front of the camera and said, look, they're gone. Right.
我只是，这让我现在很激动。这让我开始嚎啕大哭，因为我当时太害怕这些东西在我体内了。那是我开始讨厌医疗系统的“软启动”，因为我从来没有被告知隆胸手术有任何风险。我从来没有，当这家公司没有提供这些FDA批准的，对吧，植入物可能是致癌的，甚至即使是健康的植入物，那些仍然所谓的“FDA批准”的，它们正在导致这些女性变得
And I just like, it makes me emotional now. It just like made me start bawling because I was like, I was so scared to have these things inside of me. And that was like my soft launch into saying I hate the medical system because I was never told that there was any risks about breast implants. I was never like when this company did not give these fda approved right implants could be cancer causing and even even healthy implants like ones that are still quote unquote fda approved they're causing these women to get
非常虚弱，人们正在公开谈论它，但同样，你没有看到它像应该被报道的那样被报道。女性每天都在做隆胸手术。正在经历性别转换的人，你知道，有些人正在经历性别转换之旅，他们确认性别所做的第一件事，当然是想要做隆胸手术，但他们不知道这些事情。没错。当你正在经历最严重的衰弱性心理健康问题时，因为我不知道经历性别焦虑是什么感觉。我从来没有经历过，但我确实知道想要彻底改变自己的身体是什么感觉，对吧？我没有胸部。我想要它们。我想要所有这些注射。
really sick people are speaking out about it but again you're not seeing it get covered like it should be getting covered women are getting breast implants every single day. People that are transitioning, you know, like, and some of these people that are experiencing like gender transition journeys, one of the first things they do to affirm their gender, of course, is to want to get like breast implants, but they don't know about these things. Right. And when you are having the worst debilitating mental health, cause I don't know what it feels like to experience gender dysphoria. I never went through, but I did know what it feels like to want to completely change my body, right? I had no breasts. I wanted them. I wanted all these injections.
我只是把自己推向了一条永久的医疗道路。注射越多，手术越多，更不用说当你接受麻醉时你的身体所经历的创伤，还有你的……外科医生知道，外科医生并不了解创伤。你有点被推向了所有这些东西。所以这些正在经历这种过渡之旅的人，或者甚至只是经历衰弱性心理健康症状并认为隆胸会让他们感觉更好的女性，她们没有意识到。这就是，当我实际上现在有点明白的时候，我经历的所有这些手术，当我处于那种“把自己塞进辣妹盒子”的旅程时，我只是在用越来越多的
And I was just putting myself down this permanent medical pathway. And the more and more injections, the more surgeries I got, nevermind just the trauma that your body goes through when you're getting put under anesthesia and getting your... Surgeons know, surgeons are not trauma informed. You're kind of getting pushed down and all this stuff. And so these people that are going through these like transitionary journeys, or even women who are just experiencing debilitating mental health symptoms and thinking that breast implants are going to make them feel better, they don't realize. And that's what, when I am actually kind of clicking into place now, all these surgeries I went through when I was on this, like shoving myself into the hot girl box journey, I was just fucking myself up with more and more
创伤、越来越多的医疗干预来摧毁自己。我变得越来越虚弱，越来越虚弱。再说一次，为什么我们不谈论这个？没错，就像，好吧，你，你，我认为这就是重点。就像，当你查看新闻时，他们会说，你知道，你可以使用哪个洗手间？那个迪士尼电影是被允许的。而我却买不起美国奶酪。你能谈谈那个吗？我们能有道路吗？没错。
trauma, more and more medical intervention. And I was just getting sicker and sicker and sicker. And again, why are we not talking about this? Right? Like, well, you, you, I think that that's the point. It's like, when you look on the news, they're like, you know, which bathroom can you use? And it was Disney movie is allowed. And it's like, I can't afford American cheese. Can you talk about that? Can we have roads? That's right.
但游戏规则是假装对话是在这两个糟糕的想法之间进行的，这样你就不会去看正在发生的一切。没错。这并不是要否定，我的许多听众，再次强调，我从我的听众那里收到了一些最美丽的留言，他们正在经历性别焦虑，正在经历过渡之旅。我的心与这些人同在，因为再次强调，我总是在播客上说，我认为他们很欣赏我不谈论任何我不知道的事情，你知道，因为再次强调，我不是合格的医疗从业者，我谈论我知道的烂事，我知道关于痛苦，是的，嗯，我知道尝试改变我的身体是什么感觉，所有这些事情，我希望每一个
But the game is to pretend that the conversation is between these two bad ideas so that you don't look at everything that's happening. That's right. And that's not to negate like so many of my listeners, again, I've gotten some of the most beautiful messages from my listeners who are experiencing gender dysphoria, who are on like a transition journey. And my heart goes out to these people because again, I always say on the podcast, and I think they appreciate that i don't speak about anything that i don't know about you know because again i'm not a qualified medical practitioner i talk about the shit that i know and i know about suffering yeah um and i know about what it's been like to try to change my body and all of these things and i wish every single
正在经历那个的人，我希望他们整合，我希望他们为自己找到最好的道路，嗯，但这只是痛苦，我不认为我们在谈论，我们没有，我只是想，我希望人们被告知关于一切风险的所有信息，无论是SSRI（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂），还是隆胸，还是肉毒杆菌，还是任何东西，就像我们需要，无论是肉毒杆菌，还是任何东西，就像我们需要谈论，好吧，是的，这可能快速解决一件事，但即使有一半的时间它也没有。但长期的后果是什么？就像，你知道，就像什么，我能戒掉这个吗？当我戒掉这个时会发生什么？当我想要，因为当你做
person that's going through that like i wish them integration i wish them finding the best path for themselves um but it's it's just painful and i don't think we're talking we're not i just want i want people to be given all the information about what the risks are for everything whether that be for an ssri whether that be for a breast implant whether that be for botox whether that be for anything like we need whether that be for Botox, whether that be for anything, like we need to be talking about, okay, yeah, this might quick fix one thing, but even half the time it doesn't. But then what are the long term? Like, you know, like what's, can I ever come off of this? What happens when I come off of this? What happens when I want to, because when you get
隆胸手术时，顺便说一句，他们不会告诉你，你需要每10年更换一次。我心想，我想成为一个70岁的老太太躺在手术台上，换上我的第六对假胸吗？不，我不想。但医生们不谈论这个。这就像，拿到钱，放进去，我们以后再处理后果。给他们用药，更换它，调整剂量。但如果我不想永远服用它呢？就像当我停止服用它时会发生什么？哦，我觉得我快要死了，因为我确实这样做了。我不得不冷火鸡式（突然停药）戒掉五种不同的精神药物，因为我失去了健康保险
breast implants, by the way, they don't tell you, you need to get these changed every 10 years. And I thought to myself, do I want to be like a 70 year old woman laying on the fucking operating table, getting my six pair of tits put in? No, I don't. But the doctors don't talk about this. It's just like, get the money, put them in, and we'll deal with the consequences later. Put them on the drug, change it, adjust the dose. But what if I don't want to be on this forever? Like what happens when I stopped taking it? Oh, I feel like I'm fucking dying because I did. I had to go cold Turkey off five different psych meds because I lost my health insurance
然后我癫痫发作了。我的意思是，这不仅仅是那个人有，我的意思是，抑郁和焦虑是可怕的，但有直接的医疗后果。我的意思是，你可能会中风，而他们不告诉你。不，他们不告诉。而且就像，我，你不知道，嗯，像那种“去他的”时刻，直到你失去健康保险。然后你去药房重新配药，而你之前一直支付大约4美元。然后他们说，哦是的，嘿，那将是500美元。
and I went to the seizure. I mean, it's not like you're, it's not just that the person has, I mean, depression and anxiety are terrible, but there are immediate medical. I mean, you can have a stroke and they don't tell you. No, they don't. And like, I, you do not know, um, like a what the fuck moment until you lose your health insurance. And then you go to the pharmacy to get your medications refilled and you have previously been paying like $4. And then they're like, oh yeah, Hey, that's going to be $500.
我说，呃，什么？我读到的所有内容都说，你需要逐渐减量。但即使逐渐减量，有时你也需要把药片拆开，只吃两小颗粒。我当时想，什么？所以我只是咬牙坚持了下来。我说，我只是要把它们全部戒掉。我戒掉了所有，我不推荐这样做。我向听众重申这一点，但我认为大多数从业者会听你的东西，他们知道这一点。我也对我的听众说，当我谈论这个时，如果可以的话，不要冷火鸡式戒药。但我做了，我活了下来。因为那是从业者无法谈论的另一件事。有时人们必须冷火鸡式戒掉这些东西。我做了。我没有选择，而医生们不喜欢，他们
And I'm like, uh, what? And everything I read said, you need to taper off of this. But even tapering off, sometimes you need to take the pills apart and just do two little granules. And I was going, what? So I just white knuckled that shit. I was like, I'm just going off them all. I went off all, which I do not recommend. I reiterate that to listeners, but I think mostly practitioners are going to be listening to your stuff and they know that. And I say that to my listeners too, when I talk about this, do not go off cold turkey if you can help it. But I did and I survived. Because that's another thing that practitioners can't talk about. Sometimes people have to go off these things cold turkey. I did. I did not have a fucking choice and the doctors don't like they
至少他们似乎不在乎，你知道，我不是说他们不在乎，当你没有创造时间和培训时，他们是否在乎并不重要，你知道，就像，最大的问题之一，我不知道你是否看过我们关于我写的关于研究的东西，但我们把研究与版权联系起来，基本上是什么可以申请专利，这是不科学的。是的，也许研究的伦理或研究的研究是科学的。使用该研究的系统是不科学的。因为当你说明CBT（认知行为疗法）是证据最充分的东西时，当你对这一件事进行99%的研究时，就像你没有平等地研究所有东西，你知道，有所有这些问题。但当你去那些实际上有
at least they don't seem to care you know that i'm not saying they don't when you don't create time or training it doesn't matter if they care you know like it's like the the one of the biggest problems i don't know if you had seen any of our stuff about research that i write but like we tied research to um copyrights basically what's's patentable, which is unscientific. Yeah, maybe the ethics of the study or the research of the study is scientific. The system that is using the study is not scientific. Because when you say CBT is the most evidence-based thing, when you do 99% of the research on this one thing, like you're not researching everything equally, you know, there's all these problems. But when you go to countries where they actually have
更多公共资助研究的国家，比如德国和瑞士，你可能会被开具乙酰半胱氨酸或在这里没有专利的东西。这就像，好吧，我们必须玩他汀类药物，你知道，我们需要抗抑郁药，我们需要抗精神病药，但我们不会开发那些，因为有所有这些沉没的研究成本。制造另一种他汀类药物要容易得多，因为这是大多数人，大多数人将是变胖并坐在电视机前看福克斯新闻需要他汀类药物的老白男。所以就是这样。所以我们无缘无故地有30种。它们都是一样的。
more kind of publicly funded research, like Germany and Switzerland, you might get prescribed an acetylcysteine or something that doesn't have a patent on it here. It's just like, okay, we got to play with the statin to, you know, like we need antidepressants, we need antipsychotics, but we won't develop those because there's all this sunk cost of research. And it's so much easier to just make another statin because it's what the most people, the most people are going to be older white guys that get overweight and sit in front of the TV and watch the Fox News and need a statin. So that's the thing. So we have 30 of them for no reason. They're all the same.
它只是一个去掉了微小基团的糖分子。不是吗？这有点像，他们喜欢在那里。你可能比我更了解它，但我读过詹姆斯·戴维斯（James Davies）的书《镇静》（Sedated），他谈到有一种药是专门针对女性的PMDD（经前焦虑障碍）销售的，你知道，就像，它实际上只是一种颜色为粉红色的抗抑郁药，它完全是同一种药，有些女人发现了，然后起诉了什么的，但我心想，这种烂事一直都在发生，而我们
It's just a sugar molecule with one little raster removed. Isn't it? It's kind of the same where they like there. And you'll probably know it better than me but i read it in uh james davies book sedated where he talked about how there was like one um a pill that was marketed to women for like pmdd you know like and it was literally just an antidepressant with the color pink and it was the exact same fucking medication and the some woman found out and like sued and everything or whatever but i'm going like this shit happens all the time and we
甚至不知道，你知道，我不是医学博士，我得说出来，是的，能力，这不是医疗建议，但如果你，你知道化学中的“消旋体”（rasper）是什么吗？不，所以就像你可以有，当你有一个小分子，有这些点，对吧，你可以让它形状不同，但它仍然是同一个分子，因为它们可以在五个位置中的一个或六个位置中的一个结合。所以仅仅因为版权法的工作方式，Prilosec（奥美拉唑）是什么，他们只是拿走了仿制药，说它只有L型消旋体。这就是你支付的费用。是L型消旋体而不是Y型，我的意思是制药业，这回到了你所说的，这可能是另一个
don't even know you know i'm not a medical doctor i gotta say that yeah ability and this isn't medical advice but if you if you do you know what a rasper is in chemistry no so like you can have like when you have the little molecule and there's like the dots right like you can have it be a different shape but it's still the same molecule because they can bond in like one of five locations or one of six locations. So just because the way copyright law work, what Prilosec is, is they just took the generic and they said it's only the L-shaped RASMR. That's what you're paying for. It's the L-shaped Rassmer instead of the y-shaped i mean pharmaceuticals it goes back to what you're saying it may be another one of the
激励机制，这就是问题所在，你知道我的意思吗？从每个行业自上而下，每个行业，科技、农场、制药、治疗行业、精神病学，所有这些事情，我越是，我曾经是，就像你说的，没有多少人知道这些东西，人们不做阅读，我就是那个人，就在三年前，四年前，也许在精神科医生的办公室里，说，请给我这个诊断，医生，像看着他一样，就像他是，你知道，上帝，是的，现在做我自己的阅读，我只是想，去他的，你不能付钱让我走进精神科医生的办公室，我不是说没有出色的精神科医生，因为我关注他们
incentives are just that's the problem you know what i mean like top down from every industry every industry tech farms uh pharmaceuticals the therapy industry like psychiatry all these things the more that i and i used to be it's like you said not many people know about this stuff not people do not many people do the reading i was that person just three and a half years ago four years ago now maybe in the psychiatrist's office saying like please give me this diagnosis doctor like looking up at him like he was like you know god yeah and now doing my own reading like i'm just like fucking you could not pay me to step into a psychiatrist's office like and i'm not saying there aren't incredible psychiatrists out there because i follow them
就像我的推特，我只用推特关注我真正喜欢的心理健康专业人士，他们中很多是精神科医生。他们中的许多人，再次强调，是在这个失败的、糟糕的模式中战斗。他们确实更倾向于那种灵性深度、心理兔子洞。但你不能，再次强调，这很罕见。所以，你不能付钱让我去。如果我在受苦，你最后找到我的地方就是在一个该死的精神科医生的办公室里。
like my twitter is like i only use twitter to follow like mental health professionals that i really like and a lot of them are psychiatrists. And many of them are like, again, fighting within this failed, like fucked up model. And they really are more into kind of these like spiritual depth, psychological rabbit holes. But you couldn't, again, it's like, it's very rare. So it's like, you couldn't pay me to go. If I'm suffering, the last place you're going to find me is in the office of a fucking psychiatrist.
因为我去了四个，我会告诉你，他们所有人都只是那样，好吧，让我们给你用这个，哦，你仍然感觉不好，让我们给你用另一个，让我们增加你的剂量，就是这样，没有超出那三个谈话要点，药物，哦，一定是错误的药物，或者哦，一定是错误的剂量，就是这样，那是唯一的谈话要点，他们不是，这对我来说很奇怪的是，当我们在80年代炸毁它时，系统没有更新，它基于不再起作用的假设，所以精神科医生过去常作为病人接受治疗，并进行治疗，他们现在不再这样做了，我爱你，如果你看某人，你必须接受分析，好吧，如果你现在看到某人作为精神科医生进行治疗，他们必须是网红，因为那是收入来源。
Because I've went to four and I'll tell you all of them were just like that okay let's put you on this oh you're still feeling bad let's put you on another one let's up your dose that was it like there was no nothing outside those three talking points medication oh it must be the wrong medication or oh it must be the wrong dose that was it that was the only talking point they're not it's it's what's weird to me is that the system didn't update when we blew it up in the 80s it's based on these assumptions that don't work anymore so psychiatrists used to one be in therapy as patients and to do therapy they don't anymore i love you if you see somebody you have to be in analysis well if you see somebody like doing therapy as a psychiatrist now, they have to be an influencer because that's the revenue stream.
就像你花所有的钱去上大学，医学，他们不喜欢心理学。无论如何，医院不想治愈。他们想治疗癌症，但不治愈它。他们想接生，因为那是盈利的。如果你看到一个广告牌，那上面就会是那个。他们真的不喜欢心理学，因为没有服务。他们就像，等等，程序在哪里？这是基于程序的医疗保健。你只是在说话。我不明白。所以你必须做的是，他们必须见你10分钟。
Like you take all this money out to go to college and medicine is they don't like psychology. Anyway, hospitals don't want to cure. They want to treat cancer, but not cure it. And they want to deliver babies because that's what's profitable. If you see a billboard, that's what's going to be on it. They don't really like psychology because there's no service. They're like, wait, where's the procedure? This is procedure-based healthcare. You're just talking. I don't get it. So what you have to do is they have to see you for 10 minutes
就像你为了上大学和学医投入了所有这些钱，但他们不喜欢心理学。总之，医院不想治愈疾病。他们想治疗癌症，而不是治愈它。他们想接生婴儿，因为那是有利可图的。如果你看到广告牌，上面写的就是这些。他们不太喜欢心理学，因为那没有服务可言。他们会想，等等，手术在哪里？这是基于手术的医疗保健。你只是在说话。我不明白。所以他们必须做的是，他们必须在10分钟内看完你的病。
and then you build $500 for that 10 minute. That's the service. They don't do therapy anymore, but for some reason they get to tell me what to do. You know, like I had somebody tell me that something that I was doing wasn't evidence-based and it was just like, you work for a midsize health insurance company that has five employees. Basically, it's just like a tax scam where you, whatever, like you exposed records to me in a way that was not traditional. Like you had somebody without a medical license writing me about a patient's records, which isn't legal, all this. No, I'm not in network with them.
然后你为那10分钟收费500美元。这就是服务。他们不再做治疗了，但出于某种原因，他们却能对我指手画脚。你知道，就像有人告诉我，我所做的事情没有循证依据，而事实是，你在一家只有五名员工的中型健康保险公司工作。基本上，这就像一场税务骗局，你以一种非传统的方式向我索要记录。比如你让一个没有医疗执照的人写信给我索要病人的记录，这不合法，诸如此类。不，我没有加入他们的网络。
I left the network, but it's like, if I'm a nurse, a nurse gets to tell me what to do. If I'm an engineer, an engineer gets to tell me what to do. If I'm a therapist, a therapist should tell me what to do. Not somebody who doesn't do this. That's so true. Why am I being managed by somebody who doesn't know what I do and has never done it? It's, I just, again, my heart goes out to, and it makes me feel happy because I have never to this day received an email from a therapist, psychiatrist, or anyone that says like, fuck you, what you're doing is damaging my profession. You know what I mean? And I have to admit, I've always been a little bit nervous of
我退出了那个网络，但就像，如果我是护士，护士可以告诉我该怎么做。如果我是工程师，工程师可以告诉我该怎么做。如果我是治疗师，治疗师就应该告诉我该怎么做。而不是一个根本不做这行的人。太对了。为什么我要被一个根本不懂我工作、也从未做过这行的人管理？我只是，再次重申，我向他们表示同情，这让我感到高兴，因为直到今天，我从未收到过任何治疗师、精神科医生或其他人的邮件，说“去你的，你做的事情正在损害我的职业”。你知道我的意思吗？我必须承认，我一直有点担心
that. Because the last thing that I ever want is I don't want to invalidate what people are doing or make them feel like one profession is all bad. And I try so hard to, in every episode I say that I'm like, I'm not saying medications bad. I'm not saying psychiatrists are bad and I'm not saying therapists are bad. I'm saying the bio, we say we have like a biopsychosocial model. Bullshit. We have a biomedical model and also we need a biopsychosocial spiritual model and we need
这一点。因为我最不想做的就是否定人们正在做的事情，或者让他们觉得某个职业一无是处。我非常努力地在每一集里说，我并不是说药物不好。我不是说精神科医生不好，也不是说治疗师不好。我说的是生物，我们说我们有生物-心理-社会模型。胡扯。我们有一个生物医学模型，而且我们需要一个生物-心理-社会-精神模型，我们需要
to actually have that, you know model and we need to actually have that you know like we need to actually have it and the bio is important you're moving things around so that you don't have to indict the environment because then you have to say things like poverty and health care and insurance and corporations then you can't so everything is moved around to make sure that they're like i mean the one of the reasons why the dsm-5 was such a move in the bad direction even from where the dsm-4tr was was they were trying to, one of the reasons why the DSM-5 was such a move in a bad direction, even from where the DSM-4TR was, was they were trying to, they thought that the, you know, the brain mind problem as we move further with the human genome, they were going to find the germ that caused these things or the gene that caused these things. They were going to be able to somehow say, this is why you're doing that. And it doesn't have anything to do with how the world you inhabit and interact with.
真正拥有那个，你知道模型，我们需要真正拥有它，你知道，就像我们需要真正拥有它一样，生物学很重要，你把事情移来移去，这样你就不用去指责环境了，因为那样你就必须谈论贫困、医疗保健、保险和企业，所以你不能这样做，因此一切都被移来移去，以确保他们……我的意思是，DSM-5之所以是一个糟糕的方向，甚至比DSM-4TR还要糟糕，原因之一就是他们试图……DSM-5之所以是一个糟糕的方向，甚至比DSM-4TR还要糟糕，原因之一就是他们试图……他们认为，你知道，随着人类基因组研究的深入，他们会找到导致这些问题的病菌或基因。他们想以某种方式说，这就是你为什么会这样做的原因。这与你所居住和互动的世界毫无关系。
And again, nobody wants to fix it. It's just the same. I just quit my tech job. And guess what? I was not the most popular. I made my way up to director level, but it was a very small company. But I'll tell you, I was a rock in the shoe of my C-levels because I would say, look, and I would do the annoying thing.
再说一次，没人想解决这个问题。这还是一样。我刚辞掉了科技工作。你猜怎么着？我并不受欢迎。我一路升到了总监级别，但那是一家非常小的公司。但我告诉你，我是高管眼中的眼中钉，因为我会说，看，我会做那些令人讨厌的事情。
I would go through all the data and make these amazing spreadsheets and show how the product sucks. The fucking usage is low. We need to fix this. Do not turn around and tell me to tell my team to do a better fucking job when your product sucks. And I wouldn't do it. But the thing is, is that that's it.
我会查看所有数据，制作这些惊人的电子表格，并展示产品有多烂。该死的使用率很低。我们需要解决这个问题。不要转过头来告诉我，让我的团队把工作做得更好，而你的产品却烂透了。我不会那样做的。但问题是，就是这样。
It's going on all over the place. It's like you, you know, like you have these meetings where it says, we want your feedback therapist. It's like, no, you don't want our feedback. We're out here on the ground working with these people that are suffering. And we know exactly what we could change to make this better. But the problem is you don't want to, and it's the same thing with people at jobs, right? Like, and they're all of us out there, the kind of people that actually shout out about it, that shout out about the dysfunction in these toxic systems, right? Our toxic families. I heard the supervisor turn beet red when I told him he was barking in a mirror.
这种情况到处都在发生。就像你，你知道，就像你参加那些会议，上面写着，我们需要你的反馈，治疗师。就像，不，你根本不需要我们的反馈。我们在一线与这些受苦的人一起工作。我们确切地知道我们可以改变什么来让情况变得更好。但问题是你不想改变，这和人们在工作中遇到的情况是一样的，对吧？就像，我们所有人都在那里，那些真正大声疾呼的人，那些对这些有毒系统中的功能障碍大声疾呼的人，对吧？我们有毒的家庭。我听到主管在我告诉他他在对镜子咆哮时脸涨得通红。
I was like. And look, should we change our delivery? That's what I was told all the time. Like your delivery, you know, you could change your delivery. I'm like, you know what? I'm fucking tired. I'm objectively presenting you information that you asked for. And also I think you probably, I'm tired.
我当时就想。听着，我们应该改变我们的表达方式吗？我一直被这样告知。就像你的表达方式，你知道，你可以改变你的表达方式。我说，你知道吗？我他妈的累了。我客观地向你展示了你所要求的信息。而且我也认为你可能，我累了。
I don't have, I'm exhausted. I'm tired of sugarcoating things. Let's just talk. Do you want to actually just hear the truth? Because I don't know about you. I like hearing the truth. Like do I get triggered sometimes? Yeah, but I would 10 times rather someone just tell me exactly how it is rather than
我没有，我精疲力竭了。我厌倦了粉饰太平。我们直接谈吧。你真的想听真话吗？因为我不知道你怎么样。我喜欢听真话。有时候我会感到被触发吗？是的，但我宁愿有人直接告诉我真相，而不是
because I can sense when someone's bullshitting me. I respect the hell out of people that don't bullshit me. And so I never could relate to these power figures that just want to hear this sugar coated truth because the CEOs, eventually you're going to have to pay the price for this shitty product, right? Because your company is going to go under. You're not going to be able to get VC funding. It's short-term thinking.
因为我能感觉到什么时候有人在对我胡说八道。我非常尊重那些不对我胡说八道的人。所以我从来无法与那些只想听到粉饰过的真相的权力人物产生共鸣，因为首席执行官们，最终你必须为这个烂产品付出代价，对吧？因为你的公司会倒闭。你将无法获得风险投资。这是短视的思维。
The goal is what we ask you to do, make this study work. Right. And it's the same thing we're seeing in medicine now. We're seeing lots of lawsuits happening. We're seeing lots of all of these things happening. And it's because everybody just thought, oh, whatever. I don't want to talk about it. I don't want to speak out against this because of all this ideological capture that's going on.
目标就是我们要求你做的，让这项研究奏效。对。我们在现在的医学界也看到了同样的情况。我们看到很多诉讼正在发生。我们看到所有这些事情都在发生。这是因为每个人都只是想，哦，随便吧。我不想谈论它。我不想因为正在发生的这种意识形态捕获而公开反对它。
Guess what's going to make the change? It's a fraternity, too. Keep us doing the shit out of these companies. Money will talk eventually. Well, I mean, I think this stuff is so terrifying that as the problem gets bigger, less and less people are going to have the bravery to see it. And it's so much easier to believe a conspiracy theory and be like, no, this one guy or this one group is doing all of it or well if we just did this then it would fix all of it it's like no this isn't going to be fixed like that and i think one other when we started taproot every a lot of when we started taproot we when i was planning it with brie who's my business partner
猜猜什么会带来改变？这也是一种兄弟会。让我们继续从这些公司身上榨取价值。钱最终会说话的。嗯，我的意思是，我认为这些东西太可怕了，随着问题的扩大，越来越少的人会有勇气去正视它。相信阴谋论要容易得多，就像，不，是这个人或这个群体在做这一切，或者如果我们只是做了这个，那么它就会解决所有问题，就像不，这不会那样解决的，我认为当我们开始Taproot时，当我们开始Taproot时，当我和我的商业伙伴Brie计划它时
like we were like this needs to be an apple store meets a wizard's lounge design wise it needs to be like gandalf is living in the apple store because we have to say like we're going back to the 70s and doing graph psychology but we're also doing cutting edge neuroscience for trauma oh that's great and so like and everyone was like you can't do this there's this weird spacey vibe and i was like no it's going to be the 70s again like that's what we're going back to it's that level of disillusionment and then after covet everybody my age like had an astrologer you know like that's right and because what happens is like because you see it with like some of the conspiracy movements going on now is like when what happens is like people want their
我们当时想，从设计上讲，这需要是一个苹果商店遇见巫师休息室，它需要像甘道夫住在苹果商店里一样，因为我们必须说，我们要回到70年代，做图形心理学，但我们也在为创伤做尖端的神经科学，哦，那太棒了，所以每个人都说你不能这样做，有一种奇怪的空间感，我说不，这会再次成为70年代，就像我们要回到那个时代一样，那是那种程度的幻灭，然后在新冠疫情之后，我这个年纪的每个人都像有了一个占星家，你知道，那是对的，因为发生的事情是，就像你现在在一些阴谋运动中看到的那样，就像当发生的事情是，人们想要他们的
ego to be reflected by their government or their empire so like when the roman that mean the peasants eating the same gruel but when the guy is getting paraded through the street of rome and they're like yeah this is a gall we went and captured it from you this is an elephant you're like yeah it's doing my thing i like it and then the empire starts to fall apart and all of a sudden you're what happens is that it it doesn't like i'm not getting what i want anymore so i don't have this external power i have to go inward and when i go inward i build this esoteric power okay now 70 of your population believes in magic that's what happens what happens. You can't change it. You can't stop it. So when you want to say these are your two options, and they're both
自我被他们的政府或帝国所反映，所以就像当罗马人，我的意思是农民吃着同样的稀饭，但当那个人在罗马街头游行时，他们说，是的，这是我们从你们那里俘获的高卢人，这是一头大象，你就像，是的，它在做我的事，我喜欢它，然后帝国开始分崩离析，突然间你发生了什么，就是它不再像，我不再得到我想要的东西了，所以我没有这种外部力量，我必须向内看，当我向内看时，我建立了这种深奥的力量，好吧，现在70%的人口相信魔法，这就是发生的事情。你无法改变它。你无法阻止它。所以当你想要说这是你的两个选择，而且它们都
terrible, and right or left, everybody doesn't think that the government reflects their interests anymore, you're going to get essentially schizophrenia as a religion. Schizophrenia as a religion. That's a great title for a podcast episode. That's really good. There's nothing that is filtering these archetypes for you. Like if you're going in the Catholic church, at least they're being like, oh, the messianic impulse. This is what it looks like.
很糟糕，无论是右派还是左派，每个人都不再认为政府反映了他们的利益，你基本上会得到精神分裂症作为一种宗教。精神分裂症作为一种宗教。这是播客剧集的一个很棒的标题。这真的很好。没有什么东西在为你过滤这些原型。就像如果你走进天主教堂，至少他们会说，哦，弥赛亚的冲动。这就是它的样子。
Yeah. Good mother. This is what it looks like. This is the emissary that is connecting you between God and the shame. This is a ritual for shame and guilt so that you're not psychotic. And there's this buffer when you just turn all of that stuff on i mean things break which is what's happening i mean it's system overload right and also i think what we're seeing too now and and again that is a need that my podcast has stepped in and filled but ironically i didn't even know it is like
是的。好母亲。这就是它的样子。这是连接你和上帝与羞耻之间的使者。这是一种关于羞耻和内疚的仪式，这样你就不会精神错乱。当你把所有这些东西都打开时，有一个缓冲，我的意思是事情会崩溃，这就是正在发生的事情，我的意思是这是系统过载，对吧？而且我也认为我们现在看到的，再次重申，这是我的播客介入并填补的一个需求，但讽刺的是，我甚至不知道它是
my own journey on my podcast was kind of my like, I realized how spiritually starved I was because I was super agnostic. I rejected anything spiritual because I had just seen how like hypocritical it all was. And then I also was super turned off by like new age stuff. And so I was going like, but then I found up psychology. Then I found like mysticismicism mythology and archetypes and all these things and i thought okay here's a framework that i can actually use and also using the same language stolen from you vice versa that's right and the way you tell if it's a cult or not is you say is this person saying i invented it i invented it or the intuition is a
我在播客上的个人旅程有点像我的，我意识到我是多么的精神匮乏，因为我是一个超级不可知论者。我拒绝任何精神上的东西，因为我刚刚看到了这一切是多么虚伪。然后我也对新时代的东西非常反感。所以我当时想，但后来我发现了荣格心理学。然后我发现了神秘主义、神话和原型以及所有这些东西，我想好吧，这是一个我实际上可以使用的框架，而且也使用了从你那里偷来的同样的语言，反之亦然，那是对的，判断它是否是邪教的方法是你问，这个人是在说我发明了它，我发明了它，还是直觉是一个
radio and i'm just picking up on this perennial philosophy and i'm pushing you towards the door or no i did it and here's my seven points i i am an instrument of this information right like and also what i say over and over on my podcast to people is like i think that's also part of the success of it is because i do not position myself as somebody who has it all figured out right like i'm like i'm still messy and complicated and i will always be right i know that you know things that don't work don't work and i'm willing to say that but i'm not pretending that i if but i don't think anybody can really function at the highest level and achieve like individuation if they don't have some kind of connection like to a, like, um,
收音机，我只是在接收这种永恒的哲学，我是在把你推向那扇门，还是不，我做到了，这是我的七点，我是这个信息的工具，对吧？而且我在我的播客上反复对人们说的是，我认为这也是它成功的一部分，因为我并没有把自己定位为一个已经完全弄清楚这一切的人，对吧？就像我仍然是混乱和复杂的，我永远都会是，我知道你知道那些不起作用的事情就是不起作用，我愿意说出来，但我并不假装如果……但我认为如果人们没有某种联系，就像，嗯，
let me try to put this in a way that is actually right. It's like to like this collective fabric that we're all part of. Right. Like, and however the fuck you want to like make that make sense. There's thousands of ways, like just look all over the world. You know,
让我试着以一种真正正确的方式来表达这一点。就像连接到我们都是其中一部分的集体结构。对。就像，无论你他妈的想怎么让它说得通。有成千上万种方式，就像看看世界各地。你知道，
it just so happens to me that I love Western esotericism. I really, I still like you can't put me in a catholic church and me not be like in love because i just i think that i am so drawn to like gothic cathedrals like do i want to like go fucking attend a service there no but i want to sit in there and look and be just completely like uh awestruck by the the images and the look with the stained glass and all that exactly almost exactly that same you know that quote where no catholic church is this
碰巧我热爱西方神秘主义。我真的，我仍然觉得你不能把我放在天主教堂里而不让我爱上它，因为我只是觉得我被哥特式大教堂所吸引，我想去参加那里的礼拜吗？不，但我想坐在那里看着，并被那些图像和彩色玻璃的外观所完全震撼，完全一样，你知道那句名言，没有天主教堂是
beautiful thing and i can't i'm just so moved by the beauty and i think even if it has to live in a museum it should still be around forever even if it's just a museum or something just happened right there i actually didn't know that i said it but someone would say you stole that from young right yeah exactly what we're talking about is like this is a universal feeling like i have friends who are a really close friend of mine who is muslim and she was raised that from from a young age and she's also like a fellow mysticism lover and she like wants to go on a trip with me to go see all of these like my biggest dream is to go on like a pilgrimage,
这种美丽的东西，我被这种美所感动，我认为即使它必须生活在博物馆里，它也应该永远存在，即使它只是一个博物馆，或者刚刚发生了什么，我实际上不知道我说了这句话，但有人会说你从荣格那里偷来的，对吧？是的，完全正确，我们正在谈论的是，这是一种普遍的感觉，我有朋友，我的一位非常亲密的朋友是穆斯林，她从小就被那样抚养长大，她也是一位神秘主义爱好者，她想和我一起去旅行，去看看所有这些，我最大的梦想是去进行一次朝圣，
like into like some of these different places in Europe where the black Madonna is, because I really love like this like dark feminine archetype. And I, and again, she's like obsessed with it, but she knows that like, there's something cosmic and universal about this archetype and you can get
去欧洲一些不同的地方，那里有黑圣母，因为我真的很喜欢这种黑暗的女性原型。而且，再次重申，她对此非常着迷，但她知道，关于这个原型有一些宇宙和普遍的东西，你可以从中得到
just as much from it as someone who is like um native american or muslim or sufi you know like i could just name every single religion and you would find something in it because you understand that this is like universal and so i i don't like to make a lot of like very stark claims like this, but I truly believe that you can't just be a, I think therefore I am Newtonian, like materialist person and get the full human experience. And like. That's the Edward Edinger stuff.
同样多的东西，就像一个美洲原住民或穆斯林或苏菲派的人一样，你知道，我可以列举出每一个宗教，你都会在其中找到一些东西，因为你明白这是普遍的，所以我不想做出很多非常鲜明的声明，但我真的相信你不能只是做一个“我思故我在”的牛顿式唯物主义者，并获得完整的人类体验。就像爱德华·埃丁格的东西。
You know, like he's Edward Edinger, I think is like one of the rare places where he puts Jung better than Jung puts himself. Like Jung's trying to describe it, but he doesn't really. Well, because Jung was on a manic exploration of his own psyche.
你知道，就像他是爱德华·埃丁格，我认为他是少数几个比荣格本人更好地解释荣格的地方之一。就像荣格试图描述它，但他并没有真正做到。嗯，因为荣格正在对他自己的心灵进行狂躁的探索。
I don't even think half the stuff he wrote, he didn't even want people to fucking read. Well, and then some of the stuff he did write that the family didn't want to be read. There's a coffin in Bollingen that has a bunch of the chapters from his autobiography about Tonyony wolf that they removed no shit yeah there's the so the well anyway like but ender saying like that there's
我甚至不认为他写的那些东西的一半，他甚至不想让人们他妈的读。嗯，然后他确实写了一些家人不想让人读的东西。在博林根有一个棺材，里面有他自传中关于托尼·沃尔夫的几章，他们删除了，没开玩笑，是的，所以好吧，无论如何，就像埃丁格说的那样，有
existentialism there's this objective part of the brain and like from its perspective we're a bubble on a tide of empire nothing means anything and nihilism and we're only what we see touch taste and feel and that's what's real and then there's this you know that's a very ego front of the brain prefrontal cortex thing and then there's this subjective where trauma comes from but also intuition base of the brain mystical sense of like i all is one and i'm connected and maybe we're all just like parts of god you know this is duncan trussell right you know like you know like you know so like he i love him yeah he's a modern mystic yeah and so he like he says they fight and they don't want to be in the same head like what you're saying is that from that materialist perspective if you don't learn to hold both of these you're leaving one unconscious and
存在主义，大脑中有一个客观的部分，从它的角度来看，我们是帝国潮汐上的一个泡沫，什么都没有意义，虚无主义，我们只是我们所见、所触、所尝和所感，那才是真实的，然后有一个，你知道，那是大脑前额叶皮层非常自我的东西，然后有一个主观的部分，创伤来自那里，但也是直觉，大脑的基础，神秘的感觉，就像我，万物合一，我与万物相连，也许我们都只是上帝的一部分，你知道，这是邓肯·特鲁塞尔，对吧？你知道，就像你知道，所以他，我爱他，是的，他是一个现代神秘主义者，是的，所以他就像，他说它们在打架，它们不想在同一个脑袋里，你所说的是，从那个唯物主义的角度来看，如果你不学会同时持有这两者，你就会让其中一个处于无意识状态，
it will be misappropriated and so that's where it will make you its bitch well it's that's like why like you know you have ayn rand school people that are essentially talking about the an economic system like it is a religion like if we just got rid of the regulation it would be a wonderful thing and then people who are literalizing religion and turning it into like rules and a country club you know and it's like no you're using the wrong part of the brain for the wrong thing i read something the other day that basically said like people that don't have religion they will make something their religion right and it's exactly what you're saying where it's like if we don't have religion i'm going to make like social justice my religion or i'm going to make right like my my psychiatric label my religion and you're actually acting
它会被滥用，所以这就是它会让你成为它的奴隶的地方，嗯，这就是为什么，你知道，你有安·兰德学派的人，他们基本上是在谈论一种经济体系，就像它是一种宗教，如果我们只是摆脱了监管，那将是一件美妙的事情，然后是那些将宗教字面化并将其变成规则和乡村俱乐部的人，你知道，就像不，你在用大脑错误的部分做错误的事情，我前几天读到一些东西，基本上说，没有宗教的人，他们会把某种东西变成他们的宗教，对吧？这正是你所说的，就像如果我们没有宗教，我会把社会正义变成我的宗教，或者我会把我的精神病学标签变成我的宗教，而你实际上表现得
rat like a radical fundamentalist a baptist maybe like Christian who you would hate, right? This person you identify as a super leftist and you are being just as like fanatically religious and you can't see it. And that's the problem because you're unconscious and your unconscious is making you its little bitch. Yeah. And I mean, and that's like, that's with political projection. It's like half the people who come in that are extremely, you know,
像一个激进的原教旨主义者，一个浸信会教徒，也许是基督徒，你会讨厌的，对吧？这个人你认定为超级左派，而你表现得同样狂热地宗教，你却看不出来。这就是问题所在，因为你是无意识的，你的无意识正在让你成为它的小奴隶。是的。我的意思是，这就是政治投射。就像进来的一半人，他们是非常，你知道，
unhealthy intuitions, unconscious in their right wing. What's happened is like, I was raised, don't cry. I'll give you something to cry about. I despise my own capacity for vulnerability. So I'm going to attack it externally. So anytime somebody, so it's an emotional reaction. It's not logical. Anyone says, Oh, this group of people's gay or poor or black or whatever.
不健康的直觉，无意识的右翼。发生的事情是，我从小被教育，别哭。我会给你一些哭的理由。我鄙视自己脆弱的能力。所以我打算在外部攻击它。所以每当有人，所以这是一种情绪反应。这不是逻辑。任何人说，哦，这群人是同性恋、穷人、黑人或任何其他群体。
No, they deserve that. The free market or God said that, or whatever the reason is, you know, we're bombing 13 countries that you can't name right now. No, that's for freedom. It's not a foreign policy thing. It's an emotional reaction to anytime someone is hurting, I'm on the side of the person hurting them because they're right. The lefty thing is that if you say, I am the victim, I can't change. Everything, nothing that happens to me is my fault because I can't change. So these people can't change either. Then what happens is anytime, but he says, maybe this group of people could do something or here's something that we could, no, no, no, they're totally
不，他们活该。自由市场或上帝说了，或者无论什么原因，你知道，我们正在轰炸13个你现在叫不出名字的国家。不，那是为了自由。这不是外交政策问题。这是一种情绪反应，每当有人受伤时，我就站在伤害他们的人那一边，因为他们是对的。左派的事情是，如果你说，我是受害者，我无法改变。一切，发生在我身上的一切都不是我的错，因为我无法改变。所以这些人也无法改变。那么发生的事情是，每当，但他说是的，也许这群人可以做点什么，或者这是我们可以做的事情，不，不，不，他们完全
different. And you can't, you can't do that. That's, that's sexist, racist, you know, whatever, you know, and, but they're getting in the way of something that might actually be effective to defend something that they wish was true emotionally. And, you know, as you watch, like, I don't talk about politics and therapy, people come in and, um, I um i hold a pointer you know we're doing brain spotting and they just start telling me that their political beliefs are different in a week because they're not running from this thing anymore and brain spotting works really fast i mean therapy does that anyway depth psychology will take this you into this place until the ego starts to become more porous and it's less rigid and you see that happen anyway i mean I did a lot of therapy before.
不同。你不能，你不能那样做。那是性别歧视、种族主义，你知道，无论什么，你知道，而且，但他们正在阻碍某些可能实际上有效的事情，以捍卫他们情感上希望是真的东西。而且，你知道，当你观察时，就像，我不谈论政治和治疗，人们进来，嗯，我，我拿着一个指针，你知道，我们正在做大脑定位，他们只是开始告诉我，他们的政治信仰在一周内就不同了，因为他们不再逃避这件事了，大脑定位工作得非常快，我的意思是治疗无论如何都会那样做，深度心理学将带你进入这个地方，直到自我开始变得更加多孔，它不再那么僵化，无论如何你都会看到这种情况发生，我的意思是，我之前做了很多治疗。
That happened to me by taking mushrooms. Yeah. But again, you know, the mushrooms are a nonspecific amplifier. So like if you're going to, you know, and I will say, I will say having had a really bad trip off of something that was laced with something when I was a teenager, having, I have actual experiences from being, I did not take even a tiptoe into mushrooms and by the way this is like microdosing like really setting the stage like setting and what do they say like set and setting where i have zaz in the other room telling him i'm about to do it
那是因为我吃了蘑菇才发生在我身上的。是的。但同样，你知道，蘑菇是一种非特异性的放大器。所以如果你打算，你知道，我会说，我会说，作为一个青少年，我曾经因为某种被掺了东西的东西而有过一次非常糟糕的经历，我有过真实的经历，我甚至没有在蘑菇上迈出一步，顺便说一句，这就像微剂量，真的设定了舞台，就像设定和环境，他们怎么说，就像设定和环境，我在另一个房间里有Zaz，告诉他我正要这样做
i'm in here with candles lit and like reading my middle mystical books and like upping the dose as i go and like experiencing little moments of like baby unitive consciousness, right? Like teeny little moments of like maybe what you might call like Samadhi or something, very like connected moments. But having the experience of having done them before I processed any of my own shit, right? I was being chased by like murderers and hearing voices and like it was the worst night of my life.
我在这里点着蜡烛，读着我的神秘书籍，随着我的进行增加剂量，体验着像婴儿般统一意识的小时刻，对吧？就像微小的时刻，也许你可以称之为三摩地之类的东西，非常像连接的时刻。但在我处理我自己的任何狗屎之前，我有过做过它们的经历，对吧？我被谋杀者追赶，听到声音，就像那是我一生中最糟糕的夜晚。
I actually never touched a substance after that. right? I was being chased by murderers and hearing voices. And it was the worst night of my life. I actually never touched a substance after that. I thought I was just smoking weed and I'm pretty sure it was sprayed with something or something was fucked up. It was in Wyoming. And worst night of my life. I was hallucinating and I woke up and told my best friend everything I experienced. And she goes, none of that happened. Like, bitch okay and i was like whoa so i was having some really dark dark experiences but it just goes to show like you know the set and setting but i don't think people talk about it's not just set and setting it's like have you also done any of your emotional work you know because you you again you i'm a highly i realize I'm a highly intuitive person. I do have these heightened sensitive capacities,
我实际上在那之后再也没有碰过任何物质。对吧？我被谋杀者追赶，听到声音。那是我一生中最糟糕的夜晚。我实际上在那之后再也没有碰过任何物质。我以为我只是在抽大麻，我很确定它被喷了什么东西，或者有什么东西搞砸了。那是在怀俄明州。那是我一生中最糟糕的夜晚。我产生了幻觉，我醒来后告诉了我最好的朋友我经历的一切。她说，那些都没有发生。就像，婊子好吧，我当时想，哇，所以我有一些非常黑暗的经历，但这只是表明，你知道，设定和环境，但我认为人们谈论的不仅仅是设定和环境，而是你是否也做了任何你的情感工作，你知道，因为你，再次重申，我是一个高度，我意识到我是一个高度直觉的人。我确实有这些高度敏感的能力，
but back before I had done any of this work, they were going to take me to some really dark places. Now, with my experiments, my dream is to do brain spotting and stuff like that. I would love to. You're in Austin. Have you ever encountered ETT? Because that's the place where it's's everywhere i finally have insurance now okay
但在我做任何这些工作之前，它们会把我带到一些非常黑暗的地方。现在，通过我的实验，我的梦想是做大脑定位之类的东西。我很乐意。你在奥斯汀。你遇到过ETT吗？因为那是到处都有的地方，我终于有保险了，好吧
a lot of those guys don't take it either which is but that kills me because right now like i don't know if i can i can't afford it in my budget right now i would love to maybe i can like pull like an influencer i've never done that but be like hey i interview on my podcast? Can you do pre-brain spotting for me? Is that even ethical? Can I ask that? You're a good person to ask. Because I've actually never even tried that before. The issue that you get into, a lot of therapists break this law, but it is a law. Like, it's rate changing.
那些人中有很多也不接受它，这让我很痛苦，因为现在，就像我不知道我是否能，我现在的预算负担不起，我很乐意，也许我可以像网红一样，我从来没做过，但就像，嘿，我在我的播客上采访？你能为我做预大脑定位吗？这合乎道德吗？我可以问吗？你是一个很好的人选。因为我实际上从来没有尝试过。你遇到的问题，很多治疗师违反了这条法律，但它确实是一条法律。就像，它是费率变更。
You're a medical service provider. So you can't be like, I like you 20 bucks. I don't like you 200. Isn't that sliding scale? Well, the sliding scale is saying that it is being, the sliding scale is written right. It's saying that this is being done consistently for everyone. You can't just pick the rate. You can't just say, hey, you're a mental health podcaster and I want to advertise.
你是一名医疗服务提供者。所以你不能像，我喜欢你20美元。我不喜欢你200美元。那不是滑动比例吗？嗯，滑动比例是说它正在被，滑动比例写得很好。它是说这对于每个人都是一致完成的。你不能只是选择费率。你不能只是说，嘿，你是一个心理健康播客，我想做广告。
Sometimes you want to waive your fee to do pro bono stuff, but really like you can get in a lot of trouble because somebody could say, well, he saw him for free. So that's not. I should just budget it out because I'd really love to try it. And I know you said like, this is a great place to do it. As an influencer, I mean, what we could do is like if you came to Birmingham or if I was in Austin for something like that, a lot of the ETT stuff is so big, it's hard to move it. Like it was a nightmare to try and fly with all that stuff. But like I could just say this is an information series and we could film like a YouTube.
有时候你想免除你的费用来做公益工作，但真的，你可能会惹上很多麻烦，因为有人可能会说，好吧，他免费看了他。所以那不是。我应该只是把它列入预算，因为我真的很想尝试一下。我知道你说过，这是一个很好的地方。作为一个网红，我的意思是，我们可以做的是，如果你来到伯明翰，或者如果我在奥斯汀做类似的事情，很多ETT的东西太大了，很难移动。就像试图带着所有那些东西飞行是一场噩梦。但就像我可以只是说这是一系列信息，我们可以拍摄一个YouTube。
Anything that you want to promote, if people really want to follow you on Instagram, they really you've got two shows that they go ahead and add it to your phone right now while your podcast app is out. And you're listening to this ad back from the borderline and add Night Night Bitch, which Night Night Bitch is like esoteric, you know, kind of a time story, philosophy, anthropology. But it's not quite asmr but it's done as like a go to sleep while you're listening to something interesting yeah and then back from the borderline is a lot more of what we've been talking about here um but anything else that you want to promote i mean we could just you can you can i mean if people go if people go to back from the borderline.com i even have night night bitch attached to that too so it's like back from the borderline.com will take you to everything that you
任何你想推广的东西，如果人们真的想在Instagram上关注你，他们真的，你有两个节目，他们现在就可以在你的播客应用程序打开时添加到你的手机里。而且你正在听这个广告，回到边缘（Back from the Borderline）和晚安婊子（Night Night Bitch），晚安婊子就像深奥的，你知道，某种时间故事，哲学，人类学。但它不完全是ASMR，但它就像在听一些有趣的东西时去睡觉，是的，然后回到边缘更多的是我们在这里谈论的内容，嗯，但还有什么你想推广的吗？我的意思是我们可以只是，你可以，我的意思是如果人们去backfromtheborderline.com，我甚至把晚安婊子也附在上面了，所以就像backfromtheborderline.com会带你去一切你
need. If you want to dive into any of my work, it'll take you to the podcast. I also write a lot on sub stack. So if you're the kind of person you're listening to a podcast now, so clearly like podcasts. But I write a lot on sub stack and I, I don't just like recycle content from my podcast.
需要的。如果你想深入了解我的任何作品，它会带你去播客。我也在Substack上写很多东西。所以如果你是那种人，你现在正在听播客，所以显然喜欢播客。但我确实在Substack上写很多东西，而且我，我不只是像回收我播客的内容。
I write completely unique stuff on my podcast, my sub stack. So you can subscribe to that for free. And yeah, don't just like recycle content from my podcast. I write completely unique stuff on my podcast, my sub stack. So you can subscribe to that for free. And yeah, with my podcast, a lot of people are like, where do I start? You can start from the beginning. Like if you want to start from the beginning, you'll definitely have a journey because you'll start with the Molly that is like kind of just getting red pilled into critical psychology. And like you'll see how much i've changed you know but the podcast is you can start wherever you want to um i put out um three episodes a week basically but two of them are pretty much for only my um premium subscribers i have patreon and yeah that's pretty much the plug that's that's about it well thank you so much for joining us i
我在我的播客，我的Substack上写完全独特的东西。所以你可以免费订阅。是的，不要只是回收我播客的内容。我在我的播客，我的Substack上写完全独特的东西。所以你可以免费订阅。是的，对于我的播客，很多人问，我从哪里开始？你可以从头开始。就像如果你想从头开始，你肯定会有一段旅程，因为你会从那个有点被红药丸洗脑进入批判心理学的莫莉开始。而且你会看到我改变了多少，你知道，但播客是你可以从任何你想开始的地方开始，嗯，我基本上每周发布三集，但其中两集基本上只针对我的高级订阅者，我有Patreon，是的，这基本上就是插件，就是这样，好吧，非常感谢你加入我们，我
mean again you have so much knowledge and so much diligence and like really vetting your own ideas and making sure uh that you have like a cohesive understanding of it it's like you could go in any direction and we kind of did a sampling of it but it's been a joy talking to you and i really appreciate the work that you're doing i'm so glad that there's someone out there um who's able to uh, you know, people. This world needs a lot of help. I agreed. And I feel the same about what you're doing too. So thank you to your listeners for listening to my story.
我的意思是再次重申，你拥有如此多的知识和如此多的勤奋，并且真正审查你自己的想法并确保你对它有一个连贯的理解，就像你可以朝任何方向发展，我们进行了一种抽样，但和你交谈是一种乐趣，我非常感谢你正在做的工作，我很高兴有这样一个人，能够，你知道，人们。这个世界需要很多帮助。我同意。我对你正在做的事情也有同样的感觉。所以感谢你的听众收听我的故事。
And I'd love to come back anytime. We would love to have you again. We'll have to do it. Maybe a more specialty topic would give us like a, you know, we could do it. I love a rabbit hole. So that's what this was. I was, i love that framework so anytime anytime we will hopefully see you very soon
我很乐意随时回来。我们很乐意再次邀请你。我们必须这样做。也许一个更专业的专题会给我们一个，你知道，我们可以做到。我喜欢兔子洞。所以这就是这次的内容。我当时，我喜欢那个框架，所以随时，随时，我们希望很快见到你
ghosts are only time machines just as afraid of you as you are As you are The sex lives of saints and invisible men There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
鬼魂只是时间机器，和你一样害怕你，就像你一样，圣徒和隐形人的性生活，这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。